guten abend meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren sie hören jetzt die kürzeste
begrüßung die je in der stadt frankfurt
gesprochen worden ist sein sehr herzlich
willkommen schön dass sie da sind und
nehmen sie bitte am 25 februar je zehn
freunde und bekannte mit zur wahl damit
bei uns wegen der wahlbeteiligung nicht
wieder schämen müssen dass wir das wäre
schön
dann noch einen kurzen hinweis es sind
kollegen vom hessischen rundfunk radio
und fernsehen
der hessische rundfunk wird vom 14
januar ab im radio und vom 19
januar an im fernsehen über die
einzelnen kandidaten berichten
zusätzlich zur laufenden
berichterstattung und sie werden im
internet auf fasnet auch eine
zusammenfassung dieses gespräch sehen so
das war's schon jetzt zu unseren
hauptpersonen die meine kollegen
matthias alexander und tobias rösmann
den vorstellen und werden und die beiden
werden auch wie gewohnt umsichtig durch
das gespräch für vielen dank dass sie da
sind
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr denker für die
begrüßung wir freuen uns dass sie so
zahlreich gekommen sind wir waren
überbucht doppelt überbucht aber wir
haben uns doch entschieden hier zu
bleiben aus tradition und weil es
einfach ein angenehmer raum ist ich
hoffe sie fühlen sich hier auch wohl
es handelt sich um ein bürgergespräch
das bedeutet dass auch sie zu wort
kommen werden natürlich nicht alle aber
erfahrungsgemäß melden sich auch nicht
alle aber doch eine größere anzahl von
ihnen wir werden erst hier oben
diskutieren ungefähr eine stunde lang
ein paar besonders wichtige themen
werden wir dann uns hier vornehmen die
im wahlkampf einschlägig sind und dann
wie gesagt können sie fragen stellen zu
allen dingen die sie bewegen in
frankfurt das dann in etwa einer stunde
wir beginnen mit der vorstellung der
fünf kandidatinnen und kandidaten die
wir heute eingeladen haben es sind
insgesamt 12 kandidaten das auch noch
zur vollständigkeit das ist aber einfach
nicht praktikabel nicht wir sind
durchaus gute demokraten aber wir sind
halt auch pragmatiker und haben gesagt
irgendwann muss man mal einen
schlussstrich ziehen
das ist immer auch ein bisschen
willkürlich das ist so ist uns schon
klar interessanterweise ist die
frankfurter rundschau zum gleichen
schluss strich gekommen wie wir es ja
dafür daraufhin deuten mag dass das eine
gewisse plausibilität hat wir haben fünf
eingeladen wie gesagt die wir ihnen
jetzt vorstellen werden als erste drgs
eskandari-grünberg die kandidatin der
grünen sie sitzt einer
[Applaus]
sie haben sie erkannt
ehrenamtliche stadträtin seit 2006 sie
war von 2008 bis 2016 zuständig für
integration zuvor sieben jahre lang war
sie stadtverordnete unseren zweiten gast
ich hab's ja auch erstmal herzlichen
grüßen schön dass ihr alle da sind
unseren zweiten ganztag ich herzlich
begrüßen dr med weiland sie waren von
2011 bis 2014
stadtverordnetenvorsteherin und vom 2014
bis 2017 staatssekretärin im hessischen
finanzministerium herzlich willkommen so
taten janine wissler direkt zu meiner
linken fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
im landtag dem landtag gehört sie seit
2008 an herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
dann ganz in der mitte fast wie es sich
gehört hätte ich jetzt gesagt peter
feldmann oberbürgermeister der stadt
seit 2012 und vorher war er lange jahre
nehme ich glaube genau seit 1988
stadtverordnete hier in frankfurt
herzlich willkommen erfährt man ja und
last not least volker stein von 2007 bis
2013 hauptamtlicher stadtrat hier in
frankfurt von 27 bis zu 11 zuständig für
die themen sicherheit ordnung
brandschutz helfen und märkte sie sind
seit mehr als 40 jahren fdp-mitglied
treten aber als unabhängiger kandidat zu
dieser oberbürgermeisterwahl an herzlich
willkommen herr stein so um den genius
loci gerecht zu werden haben wir uns
gedacht wir fangen nicht mit dem thema
wohnen an was vielleicht einige hier
erwartet haben
was das wir auch behandeln werden was
aber nicht 80 prozent dieser diskussion
einnehmen wird das verspreche ich ihnen
jetzt schon sondern wir fangen an mit
dem thema städtische bühnen wie sie alle
wissen steht dieses gebäude zur
disposition oder auch nicht das wollen
wir heute abend da hoffen wir heute
abend herauszubekommen wie es um dieses
gebäude steht es gibt ein gutachten das
werden sie alle verfolgt haben das
sanierungs und neubau kosten auf
ungefähr 900 millionen euro schätzt
da gab es da einige relativierungen
hinterher so richtig durchblicken tut im
augenblick niemand
es gibt verschiedene gutachten jetzt wer
neue gutachten erstellt am ende werden
wahrscheinlich so viele millionen für
gutachten ausgegeben worden seien wie
andere städte dafür brauchen eine neue
bühne zu bauen aber wir haben es ja kurz
gesagt wir wollen einfach mal auf das
auf dieses thema kommen und ich würde da
gerne mit ihnen beginnen herr feldmann
sie haben nach unserer wahrnehmung
eigentlich alle positionen schon
vertreten was die zukunft der
städtischen bühnen betrifft
sie waren für die sanierung sie haben
als ich dann aber auch mal freundlich
geäußert zu allem möglichen neubau wo
stehen sie derzeit und wo werden sie
nach der wahl stehen
ich stehe da wo ich auch auf der bühne
hier gestanden habe und ich habe es ja
einfach formuliert sehr unkompliziert
erstens erhalt des standortes zweitens
dass es keinen personalabbau geben darf
hier im gegenteil wir brauchen eine
kleine aufstockung weil natürlich die
künstlerische apparat nicht einfach aus
sich heraus läuft und das dritte genauso
selbstverständlich aus meiner sicht dass
die qualität bei einem weltklasse
theater weltklasse europa mit unzähligen
auszeichnungen erhalten werden muss dass
es mal eine position die habe ich
letztes jahr vertreten war jetzt in
einer konkurrenz zeitung abgedruckt ich
habe sie dieses jahr vertreten vertreter
heute abend wieder dass eine linie darin
vielleicht ist es zu wenig spektakulär
aber zumindest für ein paar fußnoten hat
sie der rundschau gereicht vielleicht
komme ich heute abend die faz damit ja
die routine die fußnote hätte ich jetzt
gerne noch von ihnen sie sagen sie sind
für den erhalt des standorts das sagt ja
erst mal wenig wir können einen neubau
erst sagt sehr viel weil das natürlich
auch anwesende menschen hier in diesem
raum gibt die sagen dass mit dem
standort das ist so was wie eine heilige
kuh und ein dogma ich denke nein ist es
nicht es hat eine große bedeutung der
stadt weil diejenigen die bis dahin
recht aufführungen hier die geschichte
des hauses verfolgt haben die nicht nur
fasziniert sind von wolken foyer sondern
sagen das ist ein teil auch meiner
identität meines groß werden dass man
zugang zur kultur der öffnung von kultur
auch verständnis von geben
kritik auch gesellschaftlicher kritik
sich mit diesem haus identifizieren das
ist keine pille palle position
das ist auch aus meiner sicht etwas
nicht was damals alles ist einfach nötig
ist wichtig aber die frage sanierung
oder neubau ist mit ihrer antwort wir
wollen am standort bleiben doch nicht
beantwortet richtig weil natürlich es
gibt da den bauch und den kopf der bauch
sagt guck dir mal deine nachbarn an die
neu gebaut haben ist vergleichbar mit
den früheren kumpels aus marburg die
schöne fachwerkhäuser saniert haben
und das sagt der bauch vor diese
erfahrung im familien und freundeskreis
naja die einen die neu gebaut haben
wussten vorher wie hinterher etwa was
bei rauskommt und die anderen haben
schönes fachwerkhäuser und viele offene
rechnungen gehabt
das heißt der brauch geht mir
einrichtung aber wir haben ja als
koalition als stadtregierung und sehr
klar positioniert dass im augenblick
nach der ersten runde mit diesen
gutachten wo viele bis heute auch bis
hin zu den spitzen nicht ganz
nachvollziehen können wie die einzelnen
gewerke da reingekommen sind warum man
im prinzip von den wohnungen über die
drehbühne über die kita über
verschiedene gewerke über die
werkstätten alles rein geschrieben hat
ob es nicht richtig wäre als
stadtregierung eine politische vorgabe
zu machen sie wissen ich hatte bis vor
letztes jahr in diese stadt regierungen
im stadtparlament keine mehrheit es gab
ein anderen kulturdezernenten jetzt gibt
es eine kulturdezernent hin
mir macht das das leichter weil sie
gemeinsam mit der stadtregierung die
richtigen fragen stellt immer unter dem
ziel qualität muss erhalten bleiben wenn
dazu beiträgt das ebenso über 3000 als
auch durch die wollen sich jetzt vor der
wahl nicht festlegen gibt es einen
neubau oder gibt es eine sanierung
können wir das so wird der einsatz in
das allgemeine tendenz
ich habe eine tendenz und ich glaube es
ist wichtig dass wirklich punkt für
punkt auf der ms soll sich verraten
seriös durchzurechnen und wir sind ja
hier bei der zeitung mit dem klugen
köpfen die wo die menschen wissen wie
man rechnet und da gehört es eben auch
dazu dass man jedes gewerk durch prüft
also ihr klares nein es gibt keine
antwort von ihnen versuchen wir es etwas
konkreter bei frau weiland verweigern
wenn sie ihren die zukunft der
städtischen bühnen denken ist dann eher
ihre haltung groß zu denken stichwort
elbphilharmonie felder immer oder ist er
ihre vorstellung oder her ist er ihre
vorstellung sie schauen vor allem mal
auf die kosten weil ja auch der haushalt
der stadt frankfurt jetzt schon hoch
defizitär ist und 900 millionen euro
viel geld wären
ich bedanke mich erstmal für diese frage
weil diese frage abgesehen von wohnraum
eine für die stadt fragen wird der ganz
zentralen fragen für die zukunft ist aus
meiner sicht für die bürgergesellschaft
für alle diejenigen die hier schauspiel
theater oper lieben und die erste
priorität für uns alle muss doch die
sein dass wir die qualität erhalten und
wir haben gesehen in köln was passiert
wenn man im bestand saniert und
auslagert und auslagert und nochmal
auslagert die oper ist kaputt 2015 wird
sie erst wieder eröffnet werden können
und deshalb ist diese frage was machen
wir hier 2015 habe das zeug 2025 deshalb
ist diese frage was machen wir hier für
alle bürgerinnen und bürger die
entscheidende frage und deshalb ist es
natürlich eine kostenfrage und deshalb
habe ich in der öffentlichkeit geführt
gefordert dass sich experten mit diesem
thema auseinandersetzen müssen und zwar
jemand der pass von finanzen jemand der
was von architektur und jemand der was
von kultur versteht und dann müssen die
szenarien habe aber wenn man jetzt noch
mal das entasten nimmt das ist ja ein
sehr aufwendiges gutachten sechseinhalb
millionen euro hat das gekostet
unterstellen sie jetzt der
stadtregierung dass da keine expertin
beauftragt worden sind weil wenn jetzt
noch mal experten prüfen was experten
geprüft haben
dauert das ganze ja auch sehr lang nein
der kreis kann ja ganz ruhig einberufen
werden wir haben kompetente leute in
dieser stadt die das auch auf
freiwilliger basis tun würden dieses zu
erarbeiten macht sinn und es macht sind
das dann mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern
zu besprechen in einer art
bürgerversammlung oder wie auch immer
auf jeden fall ist das interesse in der
stadtgesellschaft so stark dass ich ja
einzelne und ich sehe gerade herrn
ackermann einzelne schon intensiv mit
dem thema auseinandergesetzt haben und
deshalb müssen wir aus diesem kreis
heraus dann szenarien entwickeln was
bedeutet es wenn wir im bestand sanieren
wohin lagern wir dann aus wie viel
kostet es oder müssen wir einen anderen
ort mit einem neubau versehen aber das
geht nur im einvernehmen mit bürgerinnen
und bürger das heißt sie wollen noch
weitere längere prüfungen vornehmen von
experten wollen sie am ende das hatten
sie mal angedeutet dann auch tatsächlich
die bürger in einem bürgerbegehren
entscheiden lassen
wenn man sich nicht einigen kann und das
notwendig ist selbstverständlich denn
diese entscheidung ist so wichtig wie
vor 40 jahren die entscheidung das unter
walter wallmann das mainufer entwickelt
wurde und die museumslandschaft das wird
unsere zukunft prägen und
selbstverständlich ist dass demokratie
gelebt dass man so eine entscheidende
frage dann auch abstimmung
eskandari grünberg ich gebe die hoffnung
nicht auf dass ich heute noch eine klare
antwort kriege auf meine frage ich habe
gehört bei herrn feldmann gibt es eine
tendenz frau weiterhin für die
bevölkerung abstimmen lassen über ein
ergebnis das wir noch nicht kennen haben
die grünen klare vorstellungen wissen ob
der standort hier bleiben soll ob
saniert werden soll oder neu gebaut
werden soll
wer diesmal tendenz die auch
ausgesprochen wird vielleicht ich glaube
in der tat was ich vermisse in den
letzten monaten reden wir überhaupt
nicht darüber
wir haben das zur seite geschoben diese
thema wecken op waren und dass wir
überhaupt nicht darüber geredet
ich finde wir müssen wirklich darüber
reden dass das kultur in gstadt außer
wohnen eine zentrale thema ist wir
müssen gemeinsam darüber reden dass es
auch kultur für viele menschen nicht
auch die jetzt bürgertum auch viele
jungen menschen hier in die oper gehen
ein schauspiel unwahrscheinlich wichtig
ist und daher muss mir auch mal wirklich
aufhören nur von sanyo sondern einfach
von diesem standort die historisch aus
meiner sicht unheimlicher bedeutung
hatte ende den fünfzigerjahren frankfurt
hat die nicht viel geld gehabt nach dem
krieg wurde dieses haus gebaut und ich
glaube damals haben frankfurterinnen
frankfurter auf eine kulturstadt sich
ausgesprochen
und das dürfen wir heute nicht wieder
vergessen
für mich ist wichtig dass wir diese ort
des jahres mehrmals sehen wir geworden
wir sind im rhein-main- aber auch in
gesamtdeutschland als ein gutes haus im
kultur wirklich unheimlich bekannt
deswegen nicht weiß sander sie wollen
sofort sanieren ja oder nicht und daher
kann ich ihnen sagen für mich persönlich
denn stellen wer hat hier der standort
unwahrscheinlich historisch wo dieses
stadt wichtig ist wenn ich diese fassade
mir anschauen ich liebe dieser wasser
ich mag diese kulisse wenn eine
möglichkeit wäre dass wir sagen wir
sanieren
dann können wir immer wirklich
historisch immer erhalten
ich finde das wäre wunderbar nur eine
sache was ich vermisse
senckenberg-museum universität viele
krankenhäuser sind mit hilfe von
kulturfreunde von derjenigen die mit
senate diese stadt investiert hatten
gebaut wurden
seit monaten kulturfreunde die sehr
stolz sind sauer darüber dass wir nicht
darüber wirklich offen reden
abgesehen von mit dem bürger muss wir
ähnlich mit menschen reden die bereit
sind uns als stadt unterstützen und
diese kulturen aber vor sonne regen
brauchen aufrechterhalten interpretiere
ich sie misst wenn ich zusammenfasse sie
wissen auch noch nicht ob neubau oder
sanierung aber hinter dieser fassade
ich hab mir auch gesagt ich habe
überhaupt kein problem wenn wir wirklich
pläne haben neu bauen können weil im
moment viele sagen
der bestand ist so dass es schwierig
werden sollte dass das saniert wird wir
haben auch mit viele ja wie der kollegin
collien auch hier ausgesprochen dass sie
als schwierig sehen nach sanyo einiges
auch noch dargeboten wir da ich denke
wenn wir die möglichkeit haben beides
zusammen erhalten
da bin ich großer fan ich bin nicht
jemanden alles weg rollen neu aber wenn
das beides gemeinsam
wir haben viele erfahrungen diese stadt
da kann ich mich darum ist sehr gut an
freunde herrscht ein
sie werden jetzt gefragt worden deswegen
frage ist ja einfach direkt
sie wollen ja kein geld zur sanierung
der bühnen bereitstellen so lange nicht
alle schulen saniert und ausreichend
neue schulen in dieser stadt gebaut sind
sind sie in kultur genauso oder nein
aber ich bringe es auf den punkt weil
kein bürger in dieser stadt es verstehen
würde wenn wir 900 millionen wobei ich
diese summe anzweifle investieren für
eine eine kombination zwischen
schauspieler aus ober und kammerspiel
frau kollegin sind nämlich drei
einrichtungen die in diesem hause eine
rolle spielen
und deshalb sage ich zunächst einmal
muss die pflicht getan werden und dann
kommt die kür
aber zu ihrer ausgangsfrage zurückkommt
wofür ich bin ich gehöre nämlich der
generation an die erlebt hat wie das
bildungsbürgertum sich über die
blechbüchsen im foyer aufgeregt hat und
wir alle sehr irritiert waren was auf
einmal architektur hier in dieser in
schlatt alles vermag zu bauen
trotzdem hat sich das bildungsbürgertum
mit diesem see angefreundet
ich war in der politischen verantwortung
als wir unter dem kulturdezernenten dr
und dann später umgesetzt durch einen
semmelroth das magazin über das
kammerspiel gebaut haben da gab es eine
grundlegende untersuchung in die
bausubstanz dieses hauses und diese
grund untersuchung hat vor zehn jahren
stattgefunden roundabout und diese
untersuchung hat uns gesagt die
bausubstanz ist okay ihr könnt eine
investition die über 50 millionen und
spricht dann mit sich gebracht hat
tätigen weil die bausubstanz ist so gut
und wenn ich heute die
auseinandersetzungen zwischen professor
ihs und der kulturdezernentin sehe der
reeser also ich habe mit den
brandschutzmaßnahmen überhaupt nichts zu
tun das gibt es überhaupt nicht von
meiner seite erste auflagen gemacht habe
weil unsere brandschutzauflagen sind
schon exorbitant gut in dieser stadt ich
war mal feuerwehr der stange jahre
deshalb kenne ich das möchte hier an
dieser stelle für deutlich weniger geld
genau die kombination zwischen all
zwischen oper schauspielhaus und
kammerspiel haben und ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass wir deutlich für ein
drittel des genannten der genannten
kosten das an dieser stelle bauen können
frau wissler sie sind im landtag wie
schon gesagt deshalb wissen wir gar
nicht ganz genau wo sie in dieser frage
stehen was sie bisher noch keine
gelegenheit hatten sich dazu zu äußern
jetzt sage ich jetzt einfach mal
vorteilhaft wahrscheinlich sagte die
linken-politikerin 900 millionen
erlassen sich 600 millionen sein
wenn wir mal all diese sicherheitskosten
rausrechnen die da rein gerechnet worden
sind ist es die hochkultur wert in
frankfurt so was zu investieren sei es
neubau oder sanierung also auf jeden
fall habe ich eine klare meinung dazu
sie wird nicht jedem gefallen aber ich
habe schon mal als ich habe auf jeden
fall eine klare meinung ich finde zum
ersten dass dieser standort hier
unbedingt gehalten werden muss weil
kunst und kultur gehört ins herzen der
stadt und nicht irgendwo anders hin
wir haben hier die gute öpnv-anbindung
dieser ort hier muss auf jeden fall
gehalten werden und ich möchte auch
nicht das schauspiel und oper platz
machen für den nächsten büroturm der
dann hier entstehen würde
und ich bin auch nicht da bin auch der
meinung dass kunst und kultur kein
beiwerk dieser gesellschaft sind und sie
sind auch keine kühe herrscht ein
sondern kunst und kultur sind eine
tragende säule von gesellschaft und
deswegen brauchen sie auch diesen
stellenwert und zu der frage sanierung
oder neubau habe ich die gefragt von
denen ich glaube dass sie es am besten
beurteilen können das sind die
beschäftigten hier im haus und deswegen
haben wir einen termin mit dem
betriebsrat weil ich mich die frage
natürlich der arbeitsbedingungen auch
interessiert hat und die beschäftigten
haben argumentiert und das fand ich sehr
überzeugend dass aus ihrer sicht gar
kein weg vorbei führt an einem neubau
weil einfach die sanierungskosten ich
meine man muss auch mal deutlich sagen
wenn wir über sanierung rede neben wir
hier ja nicht über 20 millionen sondern
auch über dreistellige millionenbeträge
und dann führen wir in 10 20 jahren ja
die nächste debatte wieder weil man es
nicht so sanieren kann dass es wirklich
nachhaltig ist sonders wegen wind meine
position ist der standort hier muss
gehalten werden und ich glaube dass man
einen neubau braucht nach dem was die
beschäftigten mir gesagt haben ich
möchte aber einen punkt auch noch sagen
den ich wichtig finde es wird immer
diese horrende summe genannt
ein großer teil
dieser summe sind auch die
interimsspielstätte also das finde ich
wichtig dass die ja auch mit drin sind
und ich finde dass wichtige wäre doch
eigentlich darüber nachzudenken wie man
interviews städten so gestaltet dass sie
eine gewisse nachhaltigkeit haben also
dass man sie auch danach weiter nutzen
kann was frankfurt zum beispiel den
kinder- und jugendtheater bekommt oder
so also deswegen finde ich das wichtig
dass man nicht nur über diese hohe summe
redet sondern eben auch darüber redet
dass die möglichkeit gibt kunst und
kultur auch weiter auszubauen
in dieser stadt wien oli an dem ort aber
wieso sieht dadurch die beschäftigten
die wichtigsten also ich würde jetzt mal
einfach frech behaupten die wichtigsten
sind die besucher der bühnen sollte man
die nicht tiefer holding frau hat nicht
gesagt die wichtigsten oder ich habe
gesagt das tier sind diese am besten
beurteilen können also ich verstehe ja
ich gehe sehr gerne ins schauspiel und
schaue mir ein theaterstück an aber ich
sehe nur das was eben auf der bühne
passiert und ich weiß nicht wie es bei
ihnen das aber ich sehe nicht was hinter
der bühne passiert wie die wege sind wie
die situation der technik ist wie die
garderobe die maske wie die ganze
situation ist das sieht man doch als
besucherin oder als besucher gar nicht
und deswegen finde ich es zumindest
wichtig die beschäftigten danach zu
fragen was nicht bedeutet das nicht
natürlich auch die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer dazu eine meinung haben aber
für meine ganz persönliche
meinungsbildung weil ich kann das als
besucherinnen des schauspiels kann ich
nicht so hinter die kulissen gucken dass
ich erkennen kann ob dieses gebäude
saniert werden kann oder neu gebaut
werden kann und deswegen habe ich für
meine persönliche meinungsbildung eben
mit den beschäftigten darüber gesprochen
weil mich deren position wirklich
interessiert weil die das haus seit
jahrzehnten kennen und einfach auch gut
beurteilen können was ich hier verändern
muss sein kurswechsel will das kleber
jetzt kommen wir zum lieblingsthema
aller deutschen und auch auf frankfurter
zu wohnen
frau weiland da würde ich mit ihnen
beginnen
sie haben sich im wahlkampf früh
positioniert dem sie gesagt haben dass
mit dem baugebiet an der a5 ist keine
gute idee
jedenfalls nicht so wie es stadtrat
josef von der spd präsentiert hat
nämlich zu beiden seiten der autobahn zu
bauen und wie es auch unter anderem von
ihrer partei in der schwarz rot grünen
koalition mitgetragen worden ist jetzt
frage ich sie wie wollen sie denn sonst
leute in frankfurt unterbringen die
hierher drängen ja nicht nur mit ein
paar aufstockungen in ein paar
nachkriegs siedlung oder also wir sind
alle der meinung dass wir dringend
wohnraum benötigen frage ist dann
erstmal wo und die nächste frage ist wie
zeitnah und ich bin realist ich halte
nichts davon dass man einen popanz
aufgebaut und ein neues wohngebiet
ankündigt was dann sowieso nicht
funktionieren wird aus mehreren gründen
nicht punkt eins man hat die leute vor
ort überhaupt nicht informiert die
betroffenen im ortsbeirat 7 und 8 waren
nicht informiert üblicherweise stellt
man so eine planung vor
und die umlandgemeinden sind auch nicht
mit einbezogen worden und das heißt auch
dort gibt es bei den umlandgemeinden
überall beschlüsse die sich dagegen
aussprechen deshalb habe ich gesagt der
sprung über die a5 wird nicht
funktionieren weil politisch das
handwerk schlecht war
so macht man keine politik politik
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass man
realistisch kommuniziert und die wege
geht die bekannt sind und dann im
einvernehmen entwickelt und deshalb habe
ich gesagt es wohl wird nicht
funktionieren aus diesem grund und auch
aus einem anderen grund nicht denn die
einhausung der a 5 wird so teuer sein
dass es keiner bezahlen
die einhausung der a 3 hat drei damals
387 millionen euro gekostet und dass ich
recht hatte zeigt sich in den letzten
tagen weil man zunächst gesagt hat
spielt keine rolle wir werden einhausen
jetzt wurde diskutiert ob man die a5
verlegen kann auch das hat man ad acta
gelegt weil sich herausgestellt hat
wunder dass es nicht funktioniert und
deshalb diskutieren wir über etwas was
nicht diskussionswürdig ist vielmehr
müssen uns darum kümmern dass wir
zeitnah wohnraum schaffen damit meine
ich wir müssen mehr in die fläche gehen
wir können nicht nur frankfurt für sich
denken weil frankfurt viel zu klein ist
und das heißt der wohnraum der auch um
frankfurt herum möglich ist und machbar
ist denn wir wissen alle dass 60% des
umlands wohnraum nicht genutzt werden
wobei dann aber er hat ja nun zur
frankfurter oberbürgermeisterin gewählt
und nicht zu der von steinbach und so
weiter und das ist ein ganz schön dass
wir uns auch das umland verwalten ich
würde aber gerne wissen was in frankfurt
passieren soll ja also in frankfurt kann
man auch die zunächst mal die
wohnbaugebiete umsätzen in der schublade
liegen bonames ost siesmayer gelände
liegt fertig in der schublade wird nicht
um steuergeschenke sind vielleicht 100
wohnungen
also das ist doch ausreden mehr ganz gut
siesmayer gelände soll ein
studentenwohnheim entstehen zum beispiel
das wird nicht umgesetzt wohnungen
können dort entstehen im privaten sektor
wird nichts zur förderung getan
80 prozent des wohnraums geht nicht über
die stadt sondern private sorgen dafür
wir sehen gerade zb in niederrad wie
sich wohnraum prächtig entwickelt leona
viertel werden in den nächsten 18
monaten ca 4000 wohnungen entstehen
das sind private die büroraum um nutzen
weil wir einen
neue landesbauordnung haben ist das auch
machbar
das sind viele faktoren die man
berücksichtigen muss und das ist das was
wir zeitnah umsetzen können was für die
bevölkerung in der stadt etwas bringt
und das umland bringt dann etwas wenn
man vertrauen aufbaut und mit dem umland
zusammen entwickelt wie es andere städte
schon längst machen stichwort freiburg
da wird gemeinsam mit dem
regionalverband entwickelt und so können
neue wohnbaugebiete entstehen und das
ist die agenda die wir jetzt zeitnah
fahren müssen und nicht nur ankündigen
und dann nichts mehr tun
die gefahr sehe ich wenn man erst mal
etwas in das schaufenster stellt und
sagt so das kommt dann irgendwann in 15
20 jahren hilft uns nicht weiter
der druck ist hoch wir müssen jetzt
umsetzen gut aber sie wissen ja wie hoch
das potenzial auch ist muss man sich im
detail erörtern
sie müssen ja auch für perspektiven
sorgen also wir reden auch heute müssen
wir für perspektiven sorgen den zehn
zwanzig jahren greifen
und da wäre doch vielleicht ganz gut man
würde ein großes neubaugebiet jetzt
schon angehen und welches wäre das ihrer
meinung nach ja da gibt es vom vorgänger
dem planungsdezernent kunitz mehrere
baugebiete die angedacht sind da muss
man dann mit den umlandgemeinden in ins
benehmen treten und im übrigen steinbach
wenn steinbach von dann und seite
entgegen kommt und man dann zusammen
plant ist so war es möglich aber im
moment sieht es so aus dass das
vertrauen für das umland einfach hinüber
ist es wird nicht funktionieren und
andere städte machen vor wie es geht und
warum tun wir das nicht im
regionalverband wofür haben wir sowas wo
wir haben will städte tage wo wir planen
können
das müssen wir längst angehen die
franken stadt frankfurt alleine wird
dieses thema nicht für sich lösen können
er fällt man sie sind klarer befürworter
des neuen stadtteils der geplant wird
durch den planungsdezernenten warum
schicken sie den denn eigentlich immer
so allein ins feuer wenn er nach
steinbach muss und da wieder vor den
stadtverordneten rede und antwort stehen
müssen auch in eschborn warum gehen sie
als stadtoberhaupt nicht hin und werben
stärker für diesen neuen stadtteil den
sehr befürworten es gibt im augenblick
eine noch nicht planung es gibt im
augenblick ein vorratsbeschluss der
heißt dass wir die untersuchung machen
über verschiedene alternativen
das heißt wenn man jetzt hingeht und
irgendeinen plan aushängt den es gar
nicht gibt dann macht man sich
lächerlich
es heißt die ortsbeiräte werden ganz
normal beteiligt wie das üblich ist im
üblichen ablauf wenn die planung da sind
geht das in ortsbeirat die ortsbereich
äußern sich eine beschließe
stadtparlament welchen planes haben bin
ich habe selber persönlich mit dem
bürgermeister von steinbach schon zwar
schon vor geraumer zeit gesagt dass wir
da mehr näher kooperieren müssen
oberbürgermeister brummen von oberursel
war beim ihrem dienstzimmer wir haben
gemeinsame pressemitteilung dazu gemacht
wie wir gemeinsam für preiswerten
wohnraum eintreten und das entscheidende
ist letztendlich im ergebnis und das
glaube ich ist wichtig dass wir die
einsicht dass es mehr bezahlbaren
wohnraum in frankfurt gibt auch selbst
ein stück angemessen wenn wir sagen ja
es ist schön dass wir eben niederrad
büroraum umwandeln in wohnraum 8000
einheiten
das innovationsquartier den römerhof des
vgf gelände machen bauen mit den
nachbargemeinden von gefällten walldorf
über friedberg bis auch zu unsere
lieblichen nachbargemeinde offenbar ja
wenn wir sagen wir machen
baulandentwicklung mit den anderen kommt
natürlich automatisch würde ich genauso
legitim die frage wo baut ihr denn
selber in den bereichen wohin noch
ressourcen habt und dadurch stimmt
natürlich schon der spruch sie haben es
angedeutet ich kandidiere dafür dass ich
weiter oberbürgermeister in frankfurt
möchte sein möchte und nicht der von
steinbach klar frankfurter interessen
wahrzunehmen völlig gleich sonst von
niemandem würde ich gern noch einmal
nachhaken es geht ja
in der absprache mit den kommunen mit
den umlandkommunen ja auch um
symbolpolitik es geht ja darum dass
frankfurt auf augenhöhe mit kleineren
gemeinden dort agiert deswegen noch mal
ne frage macht sich denn jetzt ja josef
lächerlich weil er eine planung vertritt
die noch nicht durch die gremien ist so
habe ich das gerade verstanden
wir haben im augenblick einen einzigen
beschluss von der cdu über die grüne spd
und einige am parlament doch
freundlicherweise mitgestimmt und diese
beschluss heißt dass wir jetzt die
untersuchung machen für künftige
planungen
das heißt jetzt irgendwo hingehen die
leute hoch wachsen in wahnsinn treiben
zu sagen na ja also mit der kaltluft
schneise hätten es gerne so mit der
holzbauweise ökologisch hätten das gerne
so der kröten wanderweg so und mit der
autobahn hätten wir es gerne so verlegt
nicht verlegt mittel fällig das ist
unverantwortlich das ist es nicht und
nase sind unseriös ist es unseriös man
muss wenn die planung fertig sind sie
dann besprechen wenn sie fertig sind
alles andere ich meine ist auch immer
die frage ist immer die frage für wen
macht man politik und ich meine es ist
schon eine entscheidung letztendlich
dafür ob man sich die für die
frankfurter interessen dafür bürgt oder
für andere ist es unsere gemarkung wir
haben das recht zu bauen
und selbstverständlich wenn wir die
steinbacher die eschborner die
oberurseler wie wir es in der
vergangenheit auch gemacht haben wenn
die planung vorlegen die gremien
reinnehmen wie werden sie beteiligen sie
werden mit entscheiden ganz punkt für
punkt wie man das also arbeiten dass das
heißt jetzt so lange die prüfung läuft
kämpfte josef allein und danach treten
sie ihm zur seite wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe
der herr josef vertritt meine interessen
tritt aber nicht alleine aus sonst hätte
ich die gespräche mit den
nachbargemeinden nicht
wir haben 14 eingeladen 12 sind gekommen
und von den zwölf haben uns zehn
baugebiete angeboten
es gibt allerdings tatsächlich in
steinbach da gibt's ja auch ein gewissen
wahlkampf in richtung landtagswahl ein
landtagskandidaten von der partei von
den stein der schon mal gute erfahrung
gemacht hatte ging es um umgehungen
straßenführung und dass er damit
bürgermeister geworden
ich würde es vielleicht wenn ich in
landtag wollte für die fdp genauso
machen
herr steigen sie sind ja doch fdp
mitglied ich weiß heute noch betonen
muss vielleicht werden wir dann sehen
und ich hab mal gedacht die es fdp seine
wachstums und wirtschaftspartei und dazu
gehört für mich eigentlich auch dass man
dafür ist dass eine stadt wächst dass es
neubaugebiete gibt dass leute die eine
wohnung suchen die ein haus bauen wollen
die viel arbeiten auch ganz ordentlich
verdienen in dieser stadt irgendwann
endlich ihre eigentumswohnung ihr haus
bauen können und da kommt herrscht ein
daher und sagt neubaugebiete finde ich
doof
können sie uns das begründen wie das wie
das zusammenpasst also herr doktor
alexander zunächst mal zu ihrer
vorbemerkung sie sind noch fdp-mitglied
ich bin nein zu mir haben zu mir zu
nehmen haben sie doch als förderung
erkläre ich muss ja nur klar sie sind
doch noch fdp mitglied ich bin in der
zwischenzeit seit 49 jahren mitglied der
freien demokraten und plane es auch über
den fünfzigsten jahrestag meiner
mitgliedschaft dieser partei zu bleiben
und habe überhaupt kein interesse bei
den politischen konkurrenten vor allem
wenn ich die diskussion heute abend
miterleben irgendwo nach meinen platz zu
suchen deshalb ich bin liberaler und ich
bleibe liberal zu der frage der
wachstumsorientierung könnte ich mir das
einfach machen und sagen ich kandidiere
als oberbürgermeister der stadt
frankfurt am main deshalb habe ich
zunächst einmal in
erster linie die interessen der
frankfurter wahrzunehmen so einfach mach
ich mir jetzt nicht weil ich war 24
jahre abgeordneter im umland verband
zehn jahre hatte ich die ehre die stadt
in der planungsversammlung beim
regierungspräsidenten mit vertreten zu
können
und in dieser zeit wurden wir von grünen
von sozialdemokraten drangsaliert doch
frischluftschneisen für die kaltluft
ströme aus dem vorderen taunus frei zu
halten also ganz viele nette sachen die
auch sinn macht und aus dieser
erkenntnis heraus gab es einen
regionalen flächennutzungsplan und
deshalb kann die stadt frankfurter
oberbürgermeister bei aller
wertschätzung ihrer person möchte ich
ihnen widersprechen wir können auch
frank vor der gelände nicht machen was
wir wollen sondern wir können nur da
bauen wo der regionale
flächennutzungsplan und planungsrecht
gibt und deshalb haben wir über
jahrzehnte diesen bereich frei gehalten
die kalk luftströme aus dem vordertaunus
bereich nach frankfurt in die innenstadt
zu bekommen habe gehört dass der
klimawandel den letzten jahre sich
verschärft hat das ist so und deshalb
muss ich dafür sorgen dass frankfurt in
diesem bereich nicht zugebaut wird
denn mit welcher begründung soll ich als
frankfurter politiker dann den
umlandkommunen oberursel steinbach
eschborn bad homburg sagen ihr habt über
jahrzehnte diesen bereich nicht zu bauen
dürfen aber jetzt bauen wir ihn zu
deshalb gibt es für mich nur eine
alternative dazu bauen wo ich eine
ähnliche zahl von wohnungen nachweisen
kann
und da will ich ihnen eine geschichte
erzählen ich habe mir eine vorher hat
kranke ja ich habe mit gerd kranke bei
der präsentation des olympia planes für
die olympiabewerbung zusammengesessen
und dann haben sich zwei kolleginnen
eine von den grünen und eine von den
sozialdemokraten darüber unterhalten
dass wir das gelände nämlich das
rebstockgelände was er für die olympiade
mal vorgesehen war
die grüne argumentierte ach du lieber
gott da fallen ja so viele migrations
grillplätze weg das können wir nicht
machen
und die andere erzählte die
sozialdemokraten erzählte was davon dass
er da so viel kleingärten war wegfallen
würden das kann man auch nicht machen
darauf hat er gerhard grandke gesagt
folge und das ist der grund weshalb
frankfurt nie mehr wieder eine größere
planung umsetzen kann
in dieser frage kann ich eben nur 100
prozent recht gehen allgemeiner meine
antwort ist die stadt frankfurt weiß es
im rebstock bereich aus ich kann dort
dieselbe zahl von wohnungen nachweisen
etwas verdichtete als das da draußen
möglich ist da draußen sind 260 hektar
im rebstock bereich sind 70 hektar aber
ich kann verdichter der bauen und kann
also her mit den den entwicklungsschub
den der stadt frankfurt hat in der
nächsten zehn zwanzig jahren damit
abrufen das rebstock aber zum 50 schon
in der kalkulation des planungsdezernats
drin ist wissen sie dass diese rechnung
die sie auch machen so die funktioniert
ist ihnen bekannt
entschuldigung wir haben wir haben das
gelände der vgf wir haben den bereich
der zulassungsstelle wir haben die schon
parat wir haben alles institutionen die
wir dort nicht dringend brauchen wir
haben wir haben das gelände wir haben
das gelände in der gutleutstraße wo bis
vor einem jahr noch die favela war
wir haben also möglichkeiten wo wir
bauen können und wir machen es nicht
weil wir nicht den migrantenfamilien
ihren grillplatz ist angekommen strömt
den entsprechenden pächtern von
kleingärten ihre kleingärten nicht
wegnehmen wollen deshalb ärgern wäre und
zwar umlandgemeinden damit herrscht an
vielen dank frau eskandari grünberg
sie sind ja eine befürworterin dieses
neuen stadtteils an der a5 haben gerade
von herrn stein gehört dass er und
andere sich um frischluftschneisen
sorgen es gibt auch viele die sagen das
sind sehr wertvolle egger die dort
ja versiegelt würden wenn das gebaut
wurde sind sie da einfach als grüne
jetzt in der falschen partei wenn sie
trotzdem dafür sind dass es gebaut wird
absolut nicht deswegen bin ich jemand
auch ein richtiger partei ich glaube wir
müssen die realität und herr steinmann
spaniens will auch die realität nicht
sehen
diese stadt wächst und wächst wie wissen
die stadt ist attraktiv viele menschen
kommen zu uns derzeit 30.000 menschen
suchen wo bezahlbaren wohnungen
eigentlich wenn man geld hat trägt man
sofort eine wohnung ist ja kein thema
wenn man aber bezahlbare rom haben
möchte kriegt man in frankfurt nicht da
müssen wir ein komplexes thema mit
wohnen auch komplexe antworten findet
seit zwei jahren haben wir in der
schublade
von den planungsdezernenten alle milieus
schutz satzungen die wir verabschiedet
haben
nord in motten an ich frage mich warum
setzen wir das nicht um da hatten wir
eine möglichkeit ein vorkaufsrecht von
der stadt dass wir gewährleisten konnte
und das wirklich umgesetzt zweite thema
ich denke in der tat wir können nicht
noch mehr einige möglichkeiten der
nachverpflichtung haben wir aber ich
glaube wir müssen darauf achten dass
diese stadt ist ein green city aufgrund
leib diese grundfläche ist für die
qualität unseres zu unserer kinder
wichtig der ist die frage wie sie hier
stellen mit den anbaugebieten
selbstverständlich stadt frankfurt von
grün von kunden gesamte fläche ist so
groß wie erfurt wenn man schaut wir
haben nicht noch mehr flächen zu zu
bauen und pflaster herrstein hat lange
geredet lassen sie mich auch mal meine
punkte die sich einbringen
daher wollte ich gerne ja herrscht dann
wenn sie nur geschichten dichtung
wahrheit sind zwei verschiedene haft
nach beute daher planen wir bayer
wahrheit und daher in der empfang ist
mir auch wichtig dass wir genau diese
komplexe fragen genauer beantworten
in der tat wir müssen mit dem hat die
frau weiland auch gesagt mit der region
gemeinsam wirklich dieses thema
behandeln bauweise von frankfurt ich
finde diese kommunikationsart die wir
den letzten
monaten gemacht und enorm falsch enorm
schief gelaufen
wir gehen auf die leute sagen wir bauen
dann ärger wie die leute und sagen na ja
vielleicht bauen wir und dann gehen wir
wieder in der ja vielleicht autobahn ein
ergebnis offen
ich finde es ist fatal wenn wir mit
unseren nachbarn nicht umgehen ich war
ein steinbach unsere jetzige
oberbürgermeister war noch nie da
deswegen auch viele ärgern sich dass man
mit den nicht reden
ich würde auch nicht meine dezernenten
an einen lassen immer eine zeit aus
integrationsdezernentin ruhig getan
in zukunft werde ich auch nicht
dezernentin allein schicken cookie wie
das ergebnis ist vielleicht gehe ich
auch mit das ist nicht die art dass wir
mit menschen mitbürger und gehen auch
mit nachbarn nicht so wißler
ich fand die diskussion um das wohnen in
den vergangenen monaten hat man ja
überraschende position erlebt die grünen
dezernentin stadträtin ist für ein
neubaugebiet am stadtrand dem
landwirtschaftliche flächen zur opfer
fallen der fdp mann ist kümmert sich um
frischluftschneisen und um
landwirtschaftliche flächen jetzt sagen
sie mir wahrscheinlich noch dass ich für
ein villenviertel an der a 5 sind
wie wie wollen sie wie stehen sie denn
jetzt zudem zu dem neubaugebiet was ist
da die option der linken sind sie dafür
bush für zwischen ökologie und und
wachstumsschmerzen der stadt wie
entscheiden sie sich da sie will nur
eine vorbemerkung machen ich will das
thema gar nicht aus frankfurt raus holen
aber ich glaube dass man alleine in
frankfurt auch die probleme der stadt
nicht lösen können wird ich glaube wir
haben einfach ein problem dass die
schwierigkeiten des ländlichen raums und
die verödung und das abhängen des
ländlichen raums natürlich probleme sind
die auch in dieser stadt rain schwappen
durch steigende mieten durch immer mehr
pendler und deswegen ist brauchen wir
natürlich auch eine vernünftige auf
landesebene regionalentwicklung dafür
sorgt dass der ländliche raum nicht
immer weiter abgehängt wird dass nicht
die kleinen schulen geschlossen werden
dass dort arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben
das ist wie ein v gibt das will ich nur
als vorbemerkung machen weil viele
menschen ziehen nach frankfurt weil sie
es gerne mögen das soll auch jeder tun
aber viele ziehen eben auch nach
frankfurt weil sie eben keine
perspektive mehr sehen und nicht keine
lust haben jeden tag aus dem vogelsberg
zu pendeln das will ich nur mal als
vorbemerkung vorneweg stellen ich finde
ja wir brauchen das neubaugebiet aber
ich finde es geht auch ein bisschen an
der diskussion eigentlich vorbei was ich
alles auf dieses neue neue baugebiet
verlagert und ich finde wir müssen doch
die frage diskutieren was das problem in
den letzten jahren auch gewesen ist wenn
wir wenn 47 prozent der bevölkerung
ihrem einkommen nach anspruch auf eine
sozialwohnung hätte und wie in frankfurt
noch knapp über 20.000 sozialwohnungen
haben dann haben wir doch eine
schieflage
und es ist doch nicht so dass in dieser
stadt nicht jede menge gebaut würde
es wird jede menge gebaut und zwar jede
menge unfug jede menge unfug ein
büroturm nach dem nächsten obwohl wir
über eine million quadratmeter
leerstehende büroflächen haben und ich
finde unter mächtigen konkretes beispiel
nennen als bockenheimer rind blutet mir
das herz was die stadt frankfurt mit den
grundstücken des ehemaligen campus
gemacht hat das waren grundstücke die
gehören der stadt frankfurt
und anstatt dass man dort bezahlbaren
wohnraum schafft wohnraum für
studierende ateliers es war mal von
kunst campus von kultur campus die rede
gewesen
dann verscherbelt die abg
diese grundstücke damit dort ein vier
sterne hotel entsteht luxus apartments
für bis zu 32 euro pro quadratmeter mit
und hunde waschplatz unten drin
das ist doch absurd und da frage ich
mich ganz ehrlich ich habe jetzt viel
gehört von frau w lan frau eskandari
grünberg lieber mit den steinbachern
umgeht das bin ich ja keine unwichtige
frage aber ich hätte mir gewünscht man
hätte auch mal sich darüber beschwert
wie mit dem bockenheimer rinnen und
bockenheim man umgegangen wurde die
jahrelang in der initiative darum
gekämpft haben und den versprechungen
und denen auch versprechungen gemacht
wurde was mit dem campus passiert und am
ende verscherbelt ist die awg und
deswegen finde ich wir müssen eigentlich
über die awg reden weil die stadt hat
ein werkzeug eine stadteigene
wohnungsbaugesellschaft und wenn diese
wohnungsbaugesellschaft ihrer aufgabe
bezahlbaren wohnraum zu schaffen nicht
nachkommt sondern genauso grundstücke
verscherbelt und sich wie ein
immobilienspekulant betätigt und selber
in die hochpreisigen segmenten geht
warum sollen die nur 40 prozent
geförderten wohnraum schaffen verstehe
ich nicht warum denn nicht 80 prozent
gehabt superzahl wurde das muss dort die
aufgabe der awg sein
aber sie kennt noch ist die kämpfe der
vergangenheit der aktuelle
planungsdezernent josef hat doch längst
verfügt und das wird ja auch umgesetzt
dass wir neubauprojekten 30 bis 40
sozialer wohnungsbau entsteht das
projekt was sie angesprochen haben am
campus war in der in der phase von herrn
kunitz meine frage zieht dann darauf
wenn sie schon den sozialen wohnraum
ansprechen was glauben sie denn ist eine
quote die verträglich ist also ich
glaube 100 prozent sozialer wohnraum in
einem quartier zu errichten ist ja auch
keine lösung da haben wir uns wieder
problemen oder welche mischung halten
sie denn für richtig ist diese 40
prozent richtig also ich finde das sind
jetzt nicht nur die fragen der
vergangenheit sondern es ist doch jetzt
ganz aktuell die frage wie hoch soll die
quote ganz speziell bei der abi diese
bei der stadteigenen
wohnungsgesellschaft 40 prozent durch
noch also ja genau 40 prozent nach
aktuellem stand ist doch okay oder nicht
nein finde ich nicht wir haben 47
prozent der frankfurter die anspruch auf
eine sozialwohnung hätten ihrem anspruch
in ihrem einkommen nach und wir haben
knapp über 20.000 sozialwohnungen da ist
eine sehr sehr große lücke sind dafür
neubauprojekt verhält wäre tatsächlich
wieder alle sozial gerecht er nicht wir
reden über 47 prozent der bevölkerung
herrscht ein aber ich mal sehr
vorsichtig mit der bezeichnung ghetto
also wir reden hier nicht nur wir reden
über menschen die die gar nicht mal das
geringste einkommen haben und vor allem
ist es doch auch so dass du größer die
zahl der öffentlich geförderten wohnung
und das sind ja nicht nur
sozialwohnungen sondern auch menschen
die lach ich drüber sind desto höher die
zahl öffentlich geförderte wohnungen ist
dass du mir hat es doch eine miet
preisdämpfende wirkung für alle menschen
in der stadt
und dafür gibt es gute beispiele wie
eben so etwas auch eine dämpfende
wirkung haben und das war nicht meine
ich nein ich war ganz konkret die frage
ich finde die awg soll das machen was in
ihrer satzung steht nämlich bezahlbaren
wohnraum zu schaffen und nicht in die
hochpreisigen segment zu gehen weil wir
davon schon überfluss haben und deswegen
finde ich 40 prozent viel zu wenig ich
finde es müsste mit ja genau die sollen
geld für die nein ich finde das ist
nicht die aufgabe der städtischen
wohnungsbaugesellschaft deren aufgabe
ist es bezahlbaren wohnraum zu schaffen
und der platz in dieser stadt ist
beschränkt und wenn man ihn weiter zu
baut mit hochpreisigen wohnen
dann fehlt sehr und deswegen finde ich
es viel zu niedrig ich finde es müsste
mindestens verdoppelt werden die ist abg
sollte 80 prozent öffentlich geförderte
wohnungen bauen mindestens weil das ist
der bedarf den wir haben uns ganz anders
ja auch ein gutes stichwort wird uns ja
vorgenommen nicht weil ich kurz erinnert
über das thema wohnen zu gehen
vielleicht mal dass ungefähr einhalten
ja ich hatte dann fällt man schon
signalisiert dass er noch einen kurzen
satz zu dem thema sagen darf das wird
das schaffen da bin ich mir ganz sicher
der hauptsatz ist ja erst mal dass wenn
man was will den satz mag ich sehr von
dem thema im grunde dann sucht man nach
lösungen wenn man was nicht viel sucht
man nach gründen und so verhält sich das
auch mit der diskussion um steinbach und
mal zurück zum fakten erstens ist die
wohnbau quote von 2000 auf 4.000
einheiten hoch
zweitens einwand wissler aber nur für
bestimmte leute wir haben jetzt
festgelegt die abb baut 10.000 wohnungen
vor allem bezahlbare wohnungen das
dritte ist dass wir sehr klar gesagt
haben mit dem mittelstandsprogramm es
wird verdoppelt ist es für die jungen
familien ist es für die jungen
polizisten erzieherinnen pflegekräfte
die leute wir brauchen die wirklichen
blechkisten morgens brauchen sondern die
wegen der stadt brauchen die
grundsatzentscheidungen die wir jetzt
letztendlich auch mit dieser
oberbürgermeisterwahl treffen ist werden
wir für unsere enkelkinder unsere
eigenen kinder noch bezahlbaren wohnraum
der stadt haben werden wir künftig
vielleicht dann an weihnachten oder zum
geburtstag postkarten kriegen bei uns in
new york oder paris fällt mal
ausführlich aber schon das jetzt schon
ein schönes schlusswort sich sicherlich
bei einer fernsehansprache halten könnt
dabei sein eigentlich bloss sein dass
für bringt jetzt in der sache einig war
nicht weiter einseitigen vereinfachen
sollte die diskussion um steinbach ist
letztendlich die version sie kennen das
mit dem acker gold ja die fünfte
fruchtfolge die stadt
abgeschlossen wird wir frieren die
bodenpreise ein dort mit diesem
instrument wenn das hinkriegen
preiswerten wohnraum dort oben im
nordwesten zu bauen und der ganze
konflikt ist im ergebnis dazu ob die
bauern dort vor ort akzeptieren dass man
in die preise vor der eigenen haustür
einfriert ich denke bei 80 bauern
730.000 leuten die wir jetzt in der
stadt haben 15.000 letztes jahr hat
ihnen die stadt gekommen sind 30.000
wohnung suchen muss die entscheidung
klar sein für das einschläfern und der
brücke der längste satz den ich je in
meinem leben gehört habe
kommen wir zum zu mir aber auch
beeindrucken kommen wir zum nächsten
thema das thema schulen das ist ein
thema was in frankfurt sehr sehr viele
gerade eltern lehrer und schüler
beschäftigt meine erste frage geht an
frau eskandari grünberg
die grünen waren fast ein
vierteljahrhundert für das
bildungsdezernat in frankfurt
verantwortlich mit zwei dezernentin
jetzt gibt es zu wenig schulen und viele
die es gibt sind marode
was würden sie denn besser machen als
ihre parteifreundin ebeling und sorge
erst mal das geht darum natürlich dass
wir auch die schulen die wir sanieren
müssen
seit letzten jahren andauern auch seine
alleine herr feldmann die letzten jahr
seinen hobbys geworden auch schulen zu
öffnen
das heißt das weniger schulen gebaut wir
müssen dennoch natürlich achten dass er
auch die schulen tatsächlich die
toiletten auch die verpflichtung hat uns
saniert werden nur was ich bedauere die
letzten monaten wir reden nicht über
bildung nicht über soziale arbeit wir
reden nicht fasst bildung leisten muss
man generieren
wir reden über toiletten ob das op
arbeit bildung selbst verstehen auch
sanieren wir müssen wir haben jetzt
allein 150 millionen hier im haushalt zu
sanieren
die muss mir nächsten jahren immer
wieder weiter genau schauen ein fehler
dass ich finde dass wir dann wirklich
auch durch liegenschaftsamt und anderen
jetzt haben wir schneider ist da dadurch
dass wir getrennt hatten dass wir auch
bildungsdezernat und auch wirklich an
dezernat haben wie sich auch gemeinsam
darum kümmern das ist aus meiner sicht
passiert in den letzten
wirklich zeit vielmehr das vieh sanieren
können aber wir müssen aufhören andauern
wenn wir ihre bildung reden über diese
situation geben wir brauchen
pädagogische arbeit wir brauchen
sozialarbeiter im moment haben wir einen
mangel lehrerinnen und lehrer
wir haben wirklich in den schulen das
problem ununterbrochen unterricht
ausfällt daher mein appell wer nächsten
jahren bildung bleibt wichtig wir haben
wir haben das thema sparen wir werden in
bildung nicht mehr
wir haben gerade groko die auch jetzt
über bildung reden
da brauchen wirklich für verbund alleine
können wir den kommunen das nicht der
fall sagt eine zentrale aufgabe dass wir
investieren okay das bedeutet aber wenn
ich sie jetzt richtig verstanden habe
dass sie was den baulichen zustand der
schulen angeht und bei allen
pädagogischen überbau der sicher wichtig
ist es glaube ich dass das was die leute
ganz konkret vor ort interessiert setzen
sie jetzt als würden sie als künftige
oberbürgermeisterin ihre hoffnung auf
einen cdu dezernenten setzen
ich würde sagen sowohl als auch wissen
sie ich würde ihn nicht immer sagen ein
gegeneinander ausspielen ich war jetzt
gerade in den schulen diskutiert die
haben gesagt sie häufig fällt unter
unserer unterricht aus wie häufig haben
wir keine für die kinder die wir
aufgenommen habe keine deutsche
sprachunterricht und deswegen will ich
werde für beides mich einsetzen so
wollen natürlich was bildung bildung
bedeutet andererseits muss schon schnell
in den nächsten jahren die schulen
sanieren
diese basic brauchen unsere kinder
brauchen der eltern brauchen statt das
ist keine debatte das muss wir in den
nächsten jahren vehement vorantreiben
und da sehen wir alle uns einig
der stein ist sie bereit
ich habe ihn ja stichwort geliefert ja
ich habe ansonsten hat ohne frage sie
waren haupt und realschullehrer in
frankfurt als sie abitur gemacht haben
gab es vielleicht zehn prozent eines
jahrgangs abitur gemacht als ich abitur
gemacht aber das glaube ich 27 holz über
50 ist dass ihre wahrnehmung nach zu
viel würden sie als oberbürgermeister
was jetzt die den schulentwicklungsplan
angeht andere eine andere richtung
einschlagen als es die aktuelle mehrheit
tut
alexander als ich abitur gemacht habe
haben sechs prozent eines jahrgangs das
abitur gemacht was sicherlich kein
erstrebenswertes ziel ist weil wir viele
talente haben liegen lassen die
allerdings über die hauptschule und
realschule auch möglichkeiten hatten
sich zu verwirklichen also dass der
hauptschulabschluss hat er damals an
anderen stellenwert als er das heute hat
heute ist die hauptschule eine
restschule von daher denke ich ist die
frage einer zahl nicht das
ausschlaggebende sondern die frage ist
was lernen unsere schüler während ihrer
schulausbildung und inwieweit werden sie
vorbereitet und qualifiziert für das vor
ihnen liegende berufsleben und da fing
die frage an alle handwerksunternehmen
alle banken alle dienstleister in dieser
stadt die ihk die handwerkskammer
beklagen sich über die
unterdurchschnittlichen abschlüsse von
hessischen schülern insbesondere von
daher noch eine ergänzung gnädige frau
schwarz grün ist im lande dran sie
können ja im herbst bei der landtagswahl
die grünen wieder wählen die seit fünf
jahren auch in hessen dran ist hier in
frankfurt geht es um die situation als
schulträger und der schulträger ist für
die bauten zuständig nicht für die
lehrerversorgung und für nichts anderes
so also wir müssen etwas daran tun dass
wir auch ein bischen wieder das niveau
unserer schüler dahin bekommen dass sie
mit dem abschluss einer eines gymnasiums
oder einer mittleren reife auch einen
zugang in die berufe haben die ganzen
dicker sie dürfen anschließend mich
fragen sie können heute davon ausgehen
dass die handwerksbetriebe dass die
industrie und handelskammern zusätzliche
prüfungen einführen die auf einmal das
abitur hinterfragen und neue kriterien
anbringen weil sie feststellen dass die
schülerinnen und schüler nicht das
deutsche mächtig sind
es gibt eine studie ja es ist so es ist
so es gibt nur studie war den bewerbern
der polizei die lehnen 60 prozent der
polizei bewerber ab nicht aus
körperlichen gründen sondern aus
rechtschreib und rechen und das ganze
nicht sein da muss in unserem
bildungssystem etwas geschehen dass
unsere anforderungen auch wieder ein
garant dafür sind dass die schülerinnen
und schüler anschließend einen nahtlosen
zugang in die hochschule oder ihnen den
berufsbildenden bereich haben herr
feldmann
herr feldmann sie haben 2005 10mal
gesagt man solle die abiturientenquote
steigern zitat bis es kracht glauben sie
tatsächlich dass alle kinder sozusagen
gleich geeignet sind fürs gymnasium
ich bin zutiefst überzeugt dass die
forderung von damals bildung und abitur
bis es kracht bis heute eine richtige
ist ich finde es nicht schlimm wenn ein
handwerksmeister die rechnungen in
verständlichem deutsch dieses
prozentrechnung perfekt und auch das was
er haben will gut begründen kann auch
junge polizisten sind nicht davor gefeit
sprachvermögen zu haben und er hilft
manchmal das abitur zumal inzwischen
auch bei den landes karriere die das
abitur voraussetzung ist um sich
bewerben zu können bei der stadt
die zwei können wir noch mit realschule
oder hauptschule realisieren
es heißt wer wirklich bildung will
sollte in der frage schulabschluss nicht
dogmatisch sein sondern soll das beste
für seine kinder wünschen und so machen
es die frankfurter eltern deshalb haben
wir fast 60 prozent abiturienten
ich denke kein elternpaar sollte sich
dafür schämen im gegenteil wir sollten
stolz sein auf unsere kinder dass es so
forsch nach vorne gehen und auch das was
wir bereich schulen jetzt baulich machen
müssen auch durch ihre kompetenz
unterstreichen frau wisla wir hatten
neulich ein sehr eindrücklichen bericht
in unserer zeitung von einer grundschule
in griesheim extrem hoher
migrantenanteil und die schulleiterin
die die stellung hält und sehr engagiert
ist in sozialen fragen sagte wir können
ja gar nicht mehr von integration reden
wir sind eigentlich nur damit
beschäftigt ein verträgliches
miteinander irgendwie zu organisieren
kann es sein dass wir gerade auch an den
schulen einen einen punkt erreichen wo
integration eben nicht mehr funktioniert
in frankfurt und was ist da zu tun um
das zu ändern
ja das problem das wir faktisch haben
aber da sind wir jetzt natürlich weniger
bei der stadtpolitik weil er jetzt für
die lehrer weniger zuständig sind aber
da sage ich gern was du ich mein das
problem ist dort das jahrelang erzählt
wurde
wir haben einen sogenannte demografische
rendite die schülerzahlen gehen zurück
und deswegen brauchen wir weniger lehrer
wurde uns jahrelang im landtag erzählt
und deswegen muss man nicht mehr lehrer
einstellen und deswegen muss man nicht
in die lehrerausbildung sondern die
schülerzahlen gehen ja zurück und ich
habe das immer für völlig falsch
gehalten und mittlerweile zeigt sich
dass sich das kultusministerium halt um
sage und schreibe 80 tausend
schülerinnen und schüler bis zum jahr
2024 verrechnet hat und wir haben
einfach einen ganz erheblichen
lehrermangel das ist ein problem das
kultusministerium selber sagt 10.000
lehrer fehlen bis 2024 nur das ist ja
ein hausgemachtes problem
also wenn man prognosen macht die damals
ja auch schon angezweifelt wurden dass
man sagt die schülerzahlen sinken
deswegen brauchen wir nicht so viele
lehrer ohne die inklusion die frage der
inklusion mit einzubeziehen die frage
der zunehmenden ganztags beschulung
natürlich auch die integration von
flüchtlingskindern also ich glaube dass
da ist doch das kernproblem dass wir
hier eine schwierigkeit haben und wenn
man dann noch schlecht mit lehrern
umgeht wie das land hessen das getan hat
und grundschullehrer schlechter bezahlt
und lehrer über die sommerferien in die
arbeitslosigkeit geschickt da damit man
sich die bezahlung in den sommerferien
spart ja dann darf man sich nicht
wundern wenn menschen in auch überlegen
ob sie den lehrerberuf ergreifen wollen
von daher finde ich hier sind politisch
in der tat riesige fehler gemacht worden
indem man einfach die schulen mit den
problemen alleine gelassen hat und sie
nicht vernünftig ausgestattet hat wir
brauchen gut ausgestattete ganze schulen
wir brauchen viel mehr schulsozialarbeit
wir haben in frankfurt die letzte zahl
die ich mal gehört dabei glaube ich
sieben schulpsychologen das ist ein witz
wir brauchen in dem bereich viel viel
mehr
und da sehe ich natürlich dass schulen
an vielen orten auch überfordert sind
bei lehrerinnen und lehrer so viel
leisten wie sie können aber eben in den
großen klassen überhaupt nicht die
möglichkeit haben zu einer individuellen
betreuung deswegen finde ich hier sind
hier fehler gemacht worden ist jetzt
weniger die stadtpolitik aber ich finde
diese probleme haben wir eben auf
landesebene haben wir jahrelang gesagt
das ist ein riesiges problem ist man
mehr an die lehrer ausbildung stecken
muss weil eigentlich klar war das ist
nicht so sein würde dass die
schülerzahlen zurückgehen
und ich finde ich freue mich gerne hören
also und das zeigt sich aber auch bei
den schulbauten also das heißt schulen
die jetzt zum beispiel teilweise auch
neu gebaut sind sind jetzt schon zu
klein
ja wir haben die situation dass die
mensa kapazitäten nicht reichen dass
kinder dann in schichten essen müssen
und so er also das heißt also die
einnahmen noch nicht hunger die anderen
haben die ganze zeitung
und da ist einfach sind einfach immense
planungsfehler gemacht worden
und wenn ich nur einen satz weil ich
jetzt zu den sanierungen aber nicht so
lang satz wie früher
ich mache einen kurzen satz ich sag nur
ich bin begeistert dass jetzt alle mal
sagen wir wollen die schulen sanieren
nur manchmal frage ich mich von dem
fordern sie das eigentlich wenn sie
regieren doch alle dann machen sie es
doch einfach und stellen sie vor allem
auch im stadtplanungsamt mehr menschen
ein weil die kommen überhaupt nicht
hinterher bei der ganzen planung
ok
ich würde tatsächlich auch gerne wieder
ein bisschen zur stadt ebene zu kommen
vor weiland und dazu was was sozusagen
die stadt leisten kann und da hat er
steiner darauf hingewiesen als
schulträger sind sie vor allem ist die
stadt vor allen dingen für die zustand
der schulen zuständig wenn man nach
einem symbol dafür sucht es ist kein
sehr appetitliches thema aber ich möchte
trotzdem ansprechen eltern und schüler
kritisieren zum beispiel dass viele
schultoiletten in einem katastrophalen
zustand sind einer stadt wie frankfurt
jetzt haben sie in ihrem masterplan
unter anderem vorgeschlagen man solle
dem problem begegnen unter anderem indem
man schüler zum toiletten scouts er
nimmt was versprechen sie sich davon
nun ja wenn ich doch etwas länger jetzt
ausruhen darf ich glaube ich hatte die
kürzeste rede hielt bisher im frau
wissler hat sich mit der landespolitik
beschäftigt dass ich außer ihnen danke
schön herr feldmann spricht davon
bildungspolitik ist abitur dass es
kracht mit krachen hat das auch nicht
viel zu tun und sagt dann das sei nicht
ihr die logisch dass ist ideologisch
weil wir alle schulformen bedienen
müssen und ich habe mich länger mit
diesem thema beschäftigt und ich bin die
einzige dieser kandidaten die das thema
bildung ganz in den fokus genommen hat
aus einer aus einem grund ich habe
selbst vier erwachsene kinder ich war
selbst lange schule elternbeirätin in
unterschiedlichen schulen
ich weiß aus der eltern sicht was man
machen muss und ich weiß auch was hier
wo der handlungsdruck besteht was hier
in der stadt nicht funktioniert was uns
die stadt ist schulträger ist für die
schulbauten für die sanierung zuständig
wir haben sanierungsstaus es fehlen neue
schulen aller schulformen und deshalb
habe ich einen masterplan für schulen
vorgestellt in der vorletzten woche der
mit experten von außen entwickelt wurde
neun punkte befinden sich in diesen
masterplan der mit einem zeitstrahl
hinterlegt ist und mit zahlen hinterlegt
ist so dass ich wenn ich
oberbürgermeisterin bin den direkt
umsetzen kann das ist solide politik aus
meiner sicht da möchte ich kurz ein
haken weil sie ja
diese punkte angesprochen abend einen
würde ich gerne ansprechen denen sie
glaube ich auch ganz nach vorne gestellt
habe sie haben gesagt die stadt braucht
eine 105 prozentige versorgung mit
schulplätzen er war jetzt ist es ja im
moment schon so dass sehr viele
gymnasiasten von a nach b kutschiert
werden müssen oder selber fahren müssen
es gibt die knappheit an den schulen wie
realistisch ist denn so ein vorschlag
105% jetzt gleich zu leisten wir
brauchen für die schüler versorgung
gerade in der stadt frankfurt und die
stadt frankfurt zeichnet sich ja dadurch
aus dass wir einen hohen
migrationsanteil haben und die
orientierung für die schulsysteme oft
später stattfindet brauchen wir ein
puffer es gibt auch viele menschen in
unserer internationalen stadt die von
außen kommen und dann brauchen wir auch
einen puffer bis sie irgendwo angekommen
sind und wissen in welcher schulform
sind dass dadurch unterscheidet sich die
stadt frankfurt von anderen städten in
hessen
und deshalb ist dieser puffer
erforderlich und das ist wieder die
landesebene da muss man dann natürlich
mit der landesebene sprechen aber wir
haben andere themen in den frankfurter
schulen
es findet keine digitalisierung stadt
bei uns in den frankfurter schulen
wir haben etwas was hier für die zukunft
wenn wir ins 21 jahrhundert mit unseren
schülerinnen und schüler entgehen wollen
überhaupt nicht vorhanden ist wir müssen
die schulen mit wlan ausstellten staaten
medienkompetenz ist erforderlich für die
schülerinnen und schüler und auch für
die lehrer
das sind die entscheidenden dinge und
wenn ich jetzt noch eins zum abschluss
dann möchte ich damit belassen weil das
dann auch zu intensiv vielleicht wird 1
zum abschluss sagen sagt im darf
interessant ist dass wir ja gerade die
koalitionsverhandlungen auf der
bundesebene haben und das was bei allen
klar ist ist dass wir mehr in bildung
investieren müssen bildung und
digitalisierung die bundesebene ist
bereit 10 milliarden zusätzlich für die
schulen zu geben und drei milliarden für
die digitalisierung die bundesebene hat
erkannt wie wichtig es ist und das
sollten wir in der stadt frankfurt weil
unsere schulen marode sind längst
umsetzen und das ist das erste was ich
angehen
[Applaus]
finanzministerium jetzt zu sagen wir
brauchen ja ja da ja also wir nähern uns
trotzdem dem vierten und letzten thema
von hier oben hier oben und dann öffnen
wir die runde zu geben
das ist das mit tabus und fragezeichen
umstellte thema integration migration
deshalb packt den stier gleich bei den
hörnern herrstein und stelle ihn eine
ganz einfache frage haben wir zu viele
migranten in frankfurt wenn sie den
strich und da alle machen ja denn wir
haben ja heute gehört ihre klage über
die berthold otto schule in griesheim
ich habe gar nicht geklappt nur was
meinen sie haben aber mitgeteilt dass
die schulleiterin der berthold otto
schule sagt integration ist hier nicht
mehr möglich weil wir heiß war es so
viele kinder mit migrationshintergrund
haben dass integration bestenfalls in
den islamischen glaubens bereich möglich
ist aber nicht dahin wo wir in
integration möglich machen wollen
nämlich in unserer gesellschaft und
wertesystem
wir müssen natürlich unterscheiden
frankfurt ist eine stadt die von
internationalen bankern auch besiedelt
ist also eine sehr internationale stadt
auch die vielen konsulate die wir hier
haben
ich glaube das ist nicht das problem der
integration das integrationsproblem ist
das natürlich jeder aus dem lande hessen
weil in frankfurt die möglichkeit
besteht geld zu verdienen
nach frankfurt kommt und da kommen
natürlich auch die unterschiedlichsten
charaktere
viele leute sind herzlich willkommen wir
haben eine internationale gesellschaft
die gerade wenn ich an die münchner
straße denke die geschäfte die wir dort
haben die von türken entsprechend
betrieben werden klammer auf deren
kinder auch am nächsten morgen in die
schule geben müssen und über unsere
junkies stolpern klammer zu so also wir
haben in der dealer szene der
polizeipräsident spricht davon dass drei
viertel der dealer szene aus
nordafrikanischen ländern kommt die
polizei spricht internes technicus von
nordafrikanischen intensivtätern oder
auch navis in rheinland pfalz wird
gerade ein gesetz beraten dass
flüchtlinge verpflichtet in den
bereichen denen sie zugeteilt sind auch
zu bleiben weil natürlich der druck auf
ball auf ein ballungsgebiet wie
frankfurt mit all ihr saßen auch schon
mit all ihrer aber es wird nie umgesetzt
weil das interessiert kein in frankfurt
weil wir sind für alles zuständig weil
wir ja eine stadt sind die irre viel
geld hat die manchmal habe ich den
eindruck zu viel geld hat weil die
schulden wachsen und wachsen
aber nichtsdestotrotz haben wir dafür zu
sorgen dass auch die frage des des
flüchtlingsstroms im lande gerecht
verteilt wird und nicht alle
möglichkeiten nach frankfurt geschoben
werden die unseren sozialkassen dann
wieder zu buche schlagen deshalb bin ich
der festen überzeugung dass wir zu viele
haben wobei das wort zu viele natürlich
zu differenzieren ist in leute die keine
integrationsschwierigkeiten haben und
andere preise die
integrationsschwierigkeiten haben wo wir
heute zum beispiel
bei in einer wohngemeinschaft mit mit
mit jugendlichen haben wo drei
sozialarbeiter zwei ausländische
jugendliche begleiten das wäre musik in
den ohren von vielen pädagogen in dieser
stadt wenn wir eine solche
klassenfrequenzen haben und deshalb bin
ich der festen überzeugung ja wir haben
unterm strich zu viele ausländer aber
einer bestimmten gruppierung in
frankfurt und das ja ja war nordafrika
nordafrika die polizei von
nordafrikanischen intensivtätern spricht
und wir nicht in der lage sind und auch
nicht in der lage sind von der polizei
festgestellt
von gerichten auch entsprechend zur
ausweisung vor das sind glaube ich erst
mal sehr schnell mal dann haben sie
erklären daran haben ein vollzugsdefizit
in dieser stadt okay jetzt würde ich als
nächstes gerne gerne die frühere
integrationsdezernentin frau eskandari
grünberg fragen wir haben früh in die
schilderung von der schule in griesheim
gehört die beschreibung der
schulleiterin
wie sehen sie denn das thema fühlen sie
sich für solche situationen auch
verantwortlich aus ihrer zeit als
integration sitzen
ich werde erst mal ich finde es
unerträglich steigen wir haben zu viel
von einem abgang von anderen ich finde
es unerträglich
deswegen ist kein wunder dass sie auch
von den ganze rechte gruppen diese
staaten unterstützen
wann kommt wir unterstützen daher ja
unerträglich weit ich finde herr becker
wie sie beim menschen reden das ist
unerträglich
das geht nicht um zuviel migranten oder
zu viele menschen
wir unterscheiden dass hier leben wir in
einer stadt die hälfte von männchen
haben einen migrationshintergrund werden
wenn wachsende stadt wir sind
wirtschaftsstarke statt
uns geht's gut in diese stadt viele
menschen wollen wir hier kommen wir sind
ein vorbild in europa selbstverständlich
wenn die menschen hier in dieser stadt
leben muss mir diese stadt mit ihrer
unterschiedliche menschen die hier haben
das gestalten
wir müssen chancengerechtigkeit chancen
möglichkeit auch unsere kinder angeben
wir müssen einfach schaffen dass die
menschen die hier leben wir haben ja
gesehen wenn sie auch diese menschen
herrscht eine einzige sekunde sich
vorstellen die migranten als diese statt
wegdenken diese stadt würde mich
funktioniert diese stadt werde über raum
erlaube ich mir auch erst man auch
einiges her ich glaube wenn wir
natürlich in den schuhen
wir müssen die rahmenbedingungen
schaffen für mich geht es überhaupt
nicht um migrantenkinder oder kein
migrant mir geht um frankfurter kinder
und daher müssen wir diese
rahmenbedingungen für alle unsere kinder
schaffen
wir müssen schauen wenn die kinder keine
deutsche sprache
da müssen wir natürlich investieren wir
müssen schauen dass wir gegen
lehrerinnen lehrer brauchen wir haben
jahrelang wir kranken kindern waren nur
in den auch schulen 90 prozent von den
kindern die waren so genannte kinder von
gastarbeitern und arbeitsmigranten die
nicht gleiche chancen haben weil ihre
eltern nicht gut ging
dass sie in der ahl schule oder ins
gymnasium gehen ich habe immer gesagt
jemand die medizin und psychotherapie
tätig ist wir haben krankenhäuser haben
wir patienten gebracht wir haben
hauptschule
da haben wir 90 prozent migranten
kindern gab die haben nicht gleiche
chancen gehabt dass die abitur machen
oder realschule heute hat die welt sich
verändert deswegen hören
auf damit auch mit der lehrerin lisa ich
nehme die probleme wirklich ernst wir
müssen handeln vor alle kinder
rahmenbedingungen schaffen die besten
lehrer die beste ausstattung gerade für
die kinder die ihre eltern sich nicht
leisten kann damit wir am schluss
kindern haben die gute ausbildung machen
kann ich bin nicht nur immer vor abitur
ich bin für die alle kinder die
kompetenzen haben die kinder die
fähigkeit haben gefordert werden und mir
ist wirklich egal wo ihre eltern wirkung
[Applaus]
nachfrage also wir haben ja sie haben
jetzt viel von fördern gesprochen aber
vielleicht kommen auch mal zum fordern
es geht ja glaub ich schon eine tendenz
die zur kenntnis davon sprach auch die
schon zweimal besagte lehrerin dass
bestimmte migranten kreise gar nicht
mehr bereit sind sich zu integrieren
oder auch für vor ihren kindern
eigentlich nicht mehr erwarten dass er
sich in dieser gesellschaft integrieren
wie gehen wir denn damit rum
selbstverständlich muss wäre integration
heißt es dass wie die chancen haben in
dem bereich wo ich als dezernentin
gearbeitet haben wir haben ganze menge
projekte für die eltern gemacht die
schüler die viele schulen waren dankbar
dass wir die eltern gewinnen konnte die
vielleicht normal nicht gewinnen kann
daher ist das auch den übergang zwischen
kindergarten und schule muss in zukunft
auch die zusammenarbeit immer wieder
verbessert werden da haben wir müssen
genau schauen dass du sagen es gibt
leute die sich nicht integrieren wolle
ja in richtung der stadt da sind auch
einige sie einige sich nicht integrieren
war holstein
da sind auch genau in der bestimmt auch
einige menschen die sich nicht
integrieren wollen da wurde ich auch
mich fragen was machen wir damit gehalt
gibt es chaos in der auch radar
integration bedeutet dass wir in einer
gesellschaft leben das wir auch
unterschiedliche menschen aus
unterschiedliche hacken miteinander
leben und wenn sie von kindern reden
wenn wir diesen kindern nicht voran
wenn wir diese kinder die möglichkeit
nehmen
dann haben wir als gesellschaft was
verloren da wurde ich von integration
verweigern sondern wir müssen in zukunft
in unserer kindern und frankfurter
kinder investieren damit wir stark
bleiben und da geht es mir wirklich
nicht darum wer verweigert sich zu
integrieren
ich glaube wenn wir rahmenbedingungen
schaffen sind eigentlich 90 prozent 95
prozent von menschen alle bereit sich zu
bewegen
nun müssen wir den raum mit ihnen davon
schaffen und da bin ich sehr
optimistisch weil hat im bahnhofsviertel
haben wir ja nun enorme missstände und
es ist auch nicht zu leugnen dass du
auch die polizei sagt wir haben es damit
mit leuten zu tun einer bestimmten
herkunft schwerpunktmäßig jetzt stellt
die cdu den sicherheits dezernenten im
bund in frankfurt stellt den
innenminister in bund und auch den
innenminister im land also ist die frage
an die cdu-kandidatin erlaubt was wird
die cdu-oberbürgermeisterin tun wenn sie
denn gewählt wird um im bahnhofsviertel
für alle bessere zustände zu sorgen dr
erlauben sie mir noch eine äußerung zu
dem thema vorhin rechtspopulismus hat in
unserer stadt nichts zu suchen
frankfurt
frankfurt zeichnet sich durch vielfalt
aus hat sich immer dadurch ausgezeichnet
und frankfurt unsere heimatstadt
integriert und jeder der hierher kommt
muss sich auch integrieren lassen und
nennen sie mir eine stadt in deutschland
wo das rathaus römer heißt weil die
italiener dort gelebt haben dass dazu
und jetzt zum thema sicherheit
sie stellen immer wieder in der
öffentlichkeit die frage war warum der
dieb ein dezernent nicht für sicherheit
sorgt wenn sie in das bahnhofsviertel
gehen sehen sie dass es nicht nur ein
dezernent ist der dort zuständig ist
sondern was die drogenproblematik
anbelangt haben haben sie den
gesundheitsdezernenten was den
aufenthalt im straßenverkehr anbelangt
haben sie den verkehrsdezernenten dann
ist noch professor birkenfeld wo für
soziales zuständig ich komme auf vier
oder vielleicht fünf dezernenten die für
diese situation im bahnhofsviertel
zuständig sind und ich habe gesagt
sicherheiten jeder großstadt ist das
wichtigste für die bevölkerung die hier
lebt und wenn ich vier oder fünf
dezernenten habe die zuständig sind dann
ist das chefsache
das kann nur der chef mit den
dezernenten zusammen regen und das ist
nicht nur in frankfurt so das ist in
jeder großstadt so dass es in hamburg
super g 20 gewesen
immer ist das der fall und deshalb
musste ich herr feldmann schon die frage
gefallen lassen warum er sich nicht um
dieses thema kümmert er hat nachhilfe
bekommen
auf der landesebene die landesebene hat
124 neue polizisten dort mit einer neuen
einheit aufgestellt und hat der stadt
frankfurt den klaren auftrag gegeben
auch ihre hausaufgaben dort zu machen
und bisher sehe ich da keine
veränderungen wir haben eine
stadtpolizei
in der stadt frankfurt die ihre aufgabe
gut erfüllt da ist mehr personal
erforderlich und man muss natürlich was
die drogenszene anbelangt dort auch
schauen wie geht man über den
sozialbereich mit dem
gesundheitsdezernenten dazu über das man
dort eine regelung vor ort trifft das
ist aufgabe der chefs der trägt die
verantwortung in dieser stadt
und da habe ich noch keine äußerung
zugehört
[Applaus]
paul wißler ich merke sie kriegen schon
wieder keine kommunalpolitische frage
diesmal mache ich sie aber nicht zum
vorwurf mich fragt so einfach
dienst nach ihrer partei wäre die
migration vermutlich mehr oder minder
unbegrenzt ließe sich dann in dieser
stadt ihrer ansicht nach noch eine
funktionierende gesellschaft
organisieren
es ist also in der tat bin ich der
meinung dass es offene grenzen für
menschen in not geben muss und ich meine
wer das nicht will muss halt über die
alternativen reden und sagen was die
alternative ist und die alternative ist
dass noch mehr menschen im mittelmeer
ertrinken so das muss man ja einfach mal
so aussprechen weil menschen die vor
kriegen fliehen die frage nicht ob die
grenze offen ist oder wie gefährlich die
flucht ist sondern die fliehen vor
bomben wie jeder von uns das machen
würde und deshalb finde ich die klage
nach offenen grenzen und an sicheren
fluchtrouten natürlich eine wichtige
frage und das sei mir noch gestartet
wenn einem ein wenn ein staat wie die
bundesrepublik waffen in alle welt
lieferten diktatoren unterstützt da darf
man sich nicht wundern dass menschen
irgendwann gezwungen sind ihre heimat zu
verlassen ich meine syrien wird auch
kranken krieg geführt mit deutschen
panzern die erdogan einsetzt also von
daher muss man eben dann auch
fluchtursachen bekämpfen
aber ich will das schon auch mal auch
auf eine weil das ist jetzt ist der
globale fragen das stimmt natürlich
gewesen
also ich mich mir missfällt das muss ich
sagen dass das thema migration und
sicherheit hier einfach schön in einen
topf gerührt wird und miteinander
diskutiert wird migration ist das könnte
so machen aber ich werde das internet
für ihn natürlich aber ich habe nur
meine meinung dazu gerne sagen wenn man
migration ist kein sicherheitsproblem
und wenn wir darüber reden dann möchte
ich nicht da möchte ich gern auch mal
darüber reden welchen
sicherheitsproblemen migranten
ausgesetzt haben massive zunahme von
rechter gewalt wir haben brennt eine
flüchtlingsheime also an der stelle
könnte man noch darüber reden anstatt
über gewalt die von flüchtlingen
vermeintlich ausgeht so das finde ich
ganz wichtig und natürlich müssen wir
fragen diskutieren aber anhand von was
ist welche angebote gibt es eben auch
und ich habe eigentlich gar keine lust
mehr über leute die vermeintlich kein
deutsch lernen wollen gedanken zu machen
solange es überhaupt nicht genug deutsch
kurse für alle gibt die das wollen und
das ist doch das problem das wir haben
und ich würde gerne dass wir darüber
reden wie wir diskriminierungen abbauen
können die wir zum beispiel an den
schulen herkunft sprachlichen unterricht
zur regel machen können damit eben auch
bilingualität gefördert wird und nicht
als irgendwie negativ dargestellt wird
und deswegen ich finde wichtig dass
keine rechts populistische
stimmungsmache auf kosten von menschen
erfolg wir brauchen die frage ob
frankfurt weniger migranten braucht die
finde ich absurd die hälfte der
frankfurterinnen und frankfurter haben
die kreation hintergrund und das ist
auch gut so und deswegen finde ich
stimmung zu machen auf kosten von
menschen mit migrationshintergrund das
ist schäbig und wer so etwas macht der
bedient einfach das geschäft der rechten
[Applaus]
bislang sei aber die frage von einer
s-bahn nicht beantwortet die frage war
nein haben sie mich die frage war gibt
es also sagen eine integrations obacht
grenze um das schreckliche wort wie sie
es wahrscheinlich finden werden zu
benutzen also gibt es aufnahme grenze
für diese gesellschaft und wo würden sie
sehen also die frage nach offenen
grenzen jetzt für die frankfurter
stadtpolitik ich finde wenn sie ganz
konkret nach kapazitätsgrenzen fragen
dann sage ich kapazitäten sind
erweiterbar es ist eine frage von
politischen willen die kapazitäten sind
die lage auf dem frankfurter
wohnungsmarkt ist nicht schlecht weil
mehr flüchtlinge kommen sind sondern
weil stadt und land den sozialen
wohnungsbau aufgegeben haben und es ist
immer eine frage von prioritäten und es
ist eine frage von politischen willen
ich sage ein beispiel wenn sie das so
konkret haben wollen wir haben momentan
die situation ist die studierendenzahlen
enorm steigen wir haben die situation
dass die hochschulen aus allen nähten
platzen ist viel zu wenig profs gibt und
die ausbildungsqualität auf dauer sinken
wird so jetzt gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
mit den problemen umzugehen das eine ist
zu sagen schotten dicht wir führen ncs
ein und machen hochschul
zulassungsbeschränkungen und eine ganze
menge leute können nicht studieren weil
die bedingungen die kapazitäten reichen
nicht das ist nicht meine antwort meine
antwort wäre dann müssen eben die
kapazitäten erweitert werden indem wir
mehr studienplätze schaffen und ich
finde die frage stellt sich doch auch
andersrum also die stellt sich doch auch
in dem bereich der migration
wenn deutschland daran beteiligt ist
fluchtursachen zu schaffen menschen vor
kriegen fliehen dann muss man doch
darüber diskutieren wie man es schafft
höhere kapazitäten zu schaffen und nicht
das gegeneinander zu diskutieren und
das ist doch sehr wohl möglich meinen in
dieser bundesrepublik war es möglich
über nacht dreistelligen milliarden für
marode banken zu beschließen
da kann es doch nicht so teuer sein viel
geringeren betrag bereit zu stellen
damit man flüchtlinge hier auch
vernünftig unterbringt und von den
ganzen law & order aposteln wie ihnen
herr stein würde ich mir wünschen dass
man sich auch mal halb so viel über die
wirklich teuren flüchtlinge in diesem
land aufregt das sind nämlich die
steuerflüchtlinge das sind die
wirtschaftskriminellen die ihr geld ins
ausland schaffen
über die kann man sich auch mal halb so
viel vielleicht aufregen über die
tatsächlich noch nicht beantwortet aber
ich gebe es jetzt mal auf entschuldigung
ich habe doch gerade darauf geantwortet
und gesagt die frage der kapazitäten ist
doch ein schulterblatt nein es die frage
stellt sich aber sie lässt sich doch
politisch beantworten
sie müssen doch sehen dass die kapazität
gibt doch keine festgelegte
kapazitätsgrenze sondern ist doch eine
frage des politischen willens wie viel
geld gibt zb die stadt dafür aus das ist
kita plätze gibt oder schule gibt also
das ist doch eine politische frage und
werden länder die sehr viel ärmer sind
sehr viel mehr flüchtlinge aufnehmen als
deutschland das tut und eine der
reichsten volkswirtschaften der welt
sagt wir machen jetzt hier aber nehmen
niemand mehr auf ihre aufnahme
einrichtungen leer stehen dann kann man
doch darüber nicht reden dass die
kapazitäten hier nicht reichen wäre mir
einfach im einsatz
wir sind sie wie viele flüchtlinge wir
in den letzten zwei jahren insgesamt
aufgenommen haben wir haben derzeit 6700
flüchtlinge vor eine stadt die 730.000
menschen
das ist die frage der kapazität da wir
reden was in der welt los ist das
mindeste was wir in dieser stadt für die
menschen tun kann daher diese kapazität
haben wir alles andere ist nur
populismus und da komm ich sagen bitte
bei fakten bleiben da kann die menschen
haben recht darauf die hier leben und
die sechs 7000 menschen die hier ja
schon sehr rasch sehr langer satz
[Applaus]
dass wir uns da ja gut so erstellt man
den diskurs kassel hinterher dann zu
zweit fortsetzen sehr gerne
ich würde jetzt gern noch mal zum
oberbürgermeister kommen es gibt ja
frankfurt profitiert hier glaube ich
auch davon dass wir hier stark
durchmischt
also was migranten angeht eine sehr
heterogene community haben anders als in
berlin in anderen deutschen großstädten
dominieren nicht bestimmte ethnischen
gruppen in einzelnen stadtteilen diese
durchmischung sorgt dafür dass die
integration besser funktioniert es gibt
aber ja doch schon auch eine tendenz in
frankfurt einer segregation hat schon
das gefühl dass in stadtteilen wie dem
nordend den innenstadtnahen stadtteilen
das sind so die privilegierten in
anführungsstrichen vielleicht ausnahme
des gallus aber sozusagen alles was
richtung norden und osten geht
glauben sie dass dass wir das weiterhin
so steuern können oder befürchten sie
schon dass das frankfurt da einem trend
folgt zehn städten in deutschland wird
beunruhigenden konsequenzen schon gibt
die segregation ist immer ein untergang
von der stadt sexy kation behindert
wirtschaft und konkret läuft es ja so
dass ihr als frankfurterin frankfurter
international deshalb gut aufgestellt
sind weil wir punkten können mit unserer
bevölkerung wenn mich in firmen besitzer
an ruft sie wissen wir haben 15.000 neue
jobs fast letztes jahr gehabt im jahr
davor ähnlich hoch die ihk prognose
47.500 und sagt herr feldmann ich hätte
gerne morgen hopp hopp 450 kita-plätze
450 wohnungen
da kann ich dem sagen wissen sie das
schaffe ich nicht bis morgen aber bringt
es doch ihre 50 besten und die anderen
400 füllen wir auf mit frankfurter
kinder neben mit abitur mit guter
bildung
die höchste internationale quote an der
ehemaligen fachhochschule heißt jetzt
ein bisschen schicker university of
applied science 57 und der höchsten
internationalen quote an der
altehrwürdigen goethe universität das
heißt frankfurt ist in der phase der
heutigen globalisierung faktisch die
spinne im netz und das ist sie nicht
seit gestern oder vorgestern sondern das
war sie schon zu den handelsrouten der
römerzeit
das war sie bei den hugenotten das weise
bei der jüdische einwanderung das heißt
die frankfurt der kinder lernen sehr
früh dass internationalität ein teil
ihrer realität und normalität ist man
kann das reduzieren da drauf indem man
auf bestimmte zeigt und ich sage ganz
einfach ich möchte weiter eine stadt
vertreten der ich sagen kann auch geben
unseren ausländischen gästen den
touristen die 100 prozent mehr kommen
den internationalen studenten den
fachkräften die kommen wir es sind die
stadt die sich ganz klar positioniert
gegen ausländerfeindlichkeit gegen
diskriminierung gegen rassismus und das
ist auch ökonomischen pluspunkt also ich
habe gar keine probleme auf dem feld
sicher es gibt immer probleme als ich
meinen wo gibt es ihn nicht ja ich bin
ja nicht naiv muss ehrlich sein aber die
frage ist worauf orientiert man sich
ich glaube dass die lösungsorientierung
ich habe das für ihn war der frage
wohnungsnot und schulen sehr klar gesagt
die lösungsorientierung ist die die
kraft der frankfurter in diesen punkten
entfaltet und wir wissen dass unsere
kinder zusammen halten dass sie auch in
den grundschulen sind 80 bis 90 prozent
migrantenkinder der peripherie
stadtteilen bei der bevölkerung bei der
bevölkerung ist es 50 prozent
wir wissen und sie wissen auch auf der
einen seite wer die u-bahn wer diese
bankhochhäuser wer die projekte wer die
siedlung gebaut hat das waren hat nicht
nur deutsche ja sie wissen auch dass sie
selber mehr chancen haben in der dritten
vierten generation mit gutem deutsch mit
gutem englisch und mit einer dritten
sprache und das sage ich den
ausländischen firmen besitzer wenn sie
herkommen
vergessen sie für ihre spiel
die trennungs gelder für die die frauen
die familien divine dass der papa wieder
weg ist und so was vergessen sie die
abfindung die business flüge die erste
klasse flüge nein wir haben lokales
personal wie sie es sonst auf der welt
weit nicht finden wir werben mit der uni
zusammen bewerben mit der
wirtschaftsförderung zusammen sie werben
mit unserem international marketing
dafür und es boomt wirklich in dieser
stadt wir werden ökonomisch nicht so gut
aufgestellt
ohne diese internationalität das heißt
wir können uns noch ein bisschen zanken
wer sich nicht integrieren mag aber wenn
wir es weg hätten dann werden wir eine
ganz stinknormale stadt die viele im
osten langweilig okay das war tiefer ist
nicht mehr jetzt ja ich lebe hier das
ist nochmals kommt ja manchmal ja ja ja
es hat muss das noch erzählen wirklich
kommen ja manchmal bürgermeister
oberbürgermeister aus dem deutschen
osten und die sagen dann wieder herr
steinacker feldmann bei uns ist es so
richtig stimmen 3 prozent migranten
handel
und wissen sie was die prognose geht auf
3,5 und da sag ich dir im arm man wissen
so was die 50 prozent hier das ist schon
ein bisschen anders als bei ihnen und
das sieht so aus als hätte man den mit
dem elektroschocker ein verpasst meine
damen und herren
wer kommt der kommt der kommt nach einer
halben stunde wieder runter meine damen
und herren der kommt nach einer halben
stunde wieder runter und er gehe ich mit
ihm raus und frankfurt es sieht eine
blühende stadt und hat spaß auch sich
ein bisschen auf die reise einzulassen
das internationalität nichts schlimmes
ist sondern unsere stadt profitiert
massiv und dafür braucht heute
unterstützung meine damen und herren so
vielen dank jetzt eröffnen wir aber
wirklich die bürgerrunde wir haben zwei
kollegen die hier mit mikrofonen
bereitstehen ich würde sie bitten mir
ein handzeichen zu geben und da versuche
ich einigermaßen gerecht vorzugehen die
sich nach wie vor ein piepen stehen sie
bitte auf wenn es irgendwie geht und
nennen sie aber anfangen ihren namen ich
finde es mal ganz schön sie müssen nicht
aber ich finde schön wenn sie es täten
das macht das ganze ein bisschen
persönlicher 800 dritte bitte habe ich
auch noch eine vierte
sie sich kurz und stellen sie am besten
eine frage wir beginnen mit der dame in
der ersten reihe bitteschön
ich sag nichts schlimmes also schönen
guten abend guten abend ich muss jetzt
leider von den höhen ihrer großen
politik die sich ja dargestellt haben
und sehr schön und auch strittig
dargestellt haben so dass wir an
eindruck hatten in die niederungen einer
kleinen bürgerin herunter holen
ich komme aus dem stadtteil seckbach ich
komme auf frankfurt nun auf den pass im
stadtteil seckbach mein name ist in
traub vorname ist monika und der
stadtteil seckbach zeichnet sich durch
zwei dinge aus wir haben zwei sehr gute
altersheime und und wir haben auch zwei
ja auch funktionierende und wir haben
zwei sehr schöne parks nämlich den hut
park und den lohrberg nicht und das sind
wunderbare naherholungsgebiete und wir
haben einen oberbürgermeister der hin
und wieder diesen stadtteil auch besucht
und so auch vor einem halben jahr
und dann fragen stellt oder sagt also
tritt so ein bisschen bei uns auf wie
der messias kommt die armen und
beladenen doch an und ich helfe euch
dann so das habe ich nun beim wort
genommen und haben natürlich auch gesagt
und habe mit dem herrn oberbürgermeister
damals einen virtuellen spaziergang über
den lohrberg gemacht und habe ihm nun
erklärt wo es überall am lohrberg
mangelt und habe das als auch plastisch
schön dargestellt und auch verständlich
und er hat auch zugehört und sagte zum
schluss nach vielleicht geben sie es mir
nochmals schriftlich hoch habe ich mit
acht selbstverständlich also ich habe
ein briefchen fertig gemacht aber es
ihnen geschrieben und habe nun jeden tag
in den briefkasten geguckt habe gedacht
es muss ja meine antwort kommt doch was
er wollte nicht wahr
also also bin ich mal
es wird noch tragisch ist wird nach
tages kam aber die arrogante bitte
relativ bald gas geben
so also ich bekam eigentlich gar nichts
in der sache habe ich nie etwas erhalten
die daraufhin habe ich nun wieder
geschrieben habe gedacht na irgendwann
musste ihn doch auch also nicht aufregen
aber x naja so können sie mir das ding
machen da sie so und dann habe ich habe
ich geld genommen und habe das nun alles
fotografiert da war also alle da ist nun
am lohrberg
es mag richtig sein vom grünflächenamt
abgeholzt worden
das mag seinen grund haben aber jeden
tag wartete ich man dass man nun das
alte cas und das ganze zumal
abtransportiert es liegt bis heute da
und das habe ich nun dem halten sie doch
mal irgendwas sie das finde ich so sieht
es aus so ersehnte das ganze abgeholzte
dort sehen sind den ganzen schrott
liegen er liegt heute noch da und das
hat mich als bürgerin geärgert ich hab
gesagt wird frauke bekommen jetzt hat
aber das gesagt er soll schreiben ich
habe geschrieben und er macht 0
ich hätte ja vor den drauf freuen
ich hätte ich hätte ja noch auf eine
antwort verzichtet wenn ihnen der pass
geschehen wer aber es ist ein rocker ist
okay vielen dank
also ich würd fast eine wette gehen dass
ein mitarbeiter davon erfährt man dass
wahrscheinlich jetzt sogar schon zum
römer rennt um diese ja die antwort dann
auf den weg zu bringen also ich denke
entweder wird das geäst weg gebracht
oder ein brief liegt übermorgen in ihrem
briefkasten
so jetzt habe ich dorthin gehöre ist
meine letzte reihe
erst sieht dann sie und dann sie dann
kommen bitteschön guten abend mein name
ist gregors ich hätte eine frage an den
bürgermeister
es wurde ja auch schon hier auf die
groko koalitionsverhandlungen verwiesen
dass das sicherlich auch bedeutung haben
kann für die stadt frankfurt nun bevor
ihre partei sich entschieden hat in die
koalitionsverhandlungen zu gehen haben
ja viele ihrer kollegen auch teilweise
aus dem langweiligen osten sich nun ihre
partei aufgerufen entsprechenden diese
koalitionsverhandlungen zu gehen
sie waren offiziell ist 'nicht zu finden
ich habe auch gegoogelt ob ich was von
ihnen zu diesem thema finde ich habe
nichts dazu gewesen jetzt frage ich mich
was ist jetzt eigentlich ihre haltung
denn die außenwahrnehmung der stadt und
die positionierung von frankfurt in der
in im land im bund ist ja ganz wichtig
muss ich das jetzt so verstehen dass sie
sich nicht dafür aussprechen wollten
weil sie denken dass eine
cdu-minderheitsregierung besser für
diese stadt ist oder ich hätte jetzt
gedacht dass sie eigentlich ja als spd
mann im zweifel ansprechpartner gerne in
die ministerien in berlin haben wollen
weil sie ja schon in wiesbaden nicht
okay die frage ist klar und fielen daher
einfach nur was ist ihre meinung dazu
hier sammelt euch erstmal ein bisschen
dann hat es ja eine herbe 2 jahren sogar
noch auch in der letzten reihe wenn sie
doch ein bisschen weiter das mikrofon
reichen
genau heute von mir aus gesehen rechts
in der
[Musik]
er ist ja wofür stehen sie nach einer
schönen guten abend mein name ist gerd
besser und wir hatten ja eingangs das
thema städtische bühnen und ich versuche
vielleicht kriegen wir jetzt diesmal zu
einer sanierungs frage als klare antwort
als vorhin von daher darf die frage
gerne derjenige beantworten dazu eine
klare meinung hat
wir reden jetzt hier über die sanierung
ein paar hundert meter weiter in der
altstadt führen der geraden umfassender
sanierung durch aber dazwischen gibt es
noch ein bauwerk das in fünf jahren 175
jahre frankfurt rationale versammlung
feiert und ich hatte welt mandaten sie
eine gastrede im oktober
graduierungsfeier von meiner uni und ich
bin persönlich ziemlich erschüttert wie
dieser bau so ein bisschen vor sich hin
vegetiert nichts passiert wir haben oben
traut einfach nur einfacher kuppel steht
lieblos da wenn ich reinkommen in dieses
foyer es ähnelt männer gruft ich hab ein
bisschen die kaiser gräber die dann doch
noch stehen könnten
und da würde ich einfach gern wissen ist
da irgendwas geplant seien es der stadt
frankfurt damals zu machen wäre das
nicht auch eine frage des bundes oder
zumindest des landes sich da zu
engagieren weil ja doch die paulskirche
als das denkmal der demokratie in
deutschland entsprechende relevanz haben
sollte man schaut neidisch nach hambach
zum schloss wie toll star gemacht wurde
und da erwarte ich eigentlich dass hier
in frankfurt auch was passiert gehen sie
bitte das mikrofon gleich weiter zu
ihrem nachbarn zu erringen
janko nahm florian müller man habe ich
hatte eine frage die frau weiland weil
ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht von
ihrer antwort auf die schultoiletten
frage also ich bin generell bisher
enttäuscht von ihren antworten weil die
herrlich udn konkret sind ich war auf
der julius-leber-schule wenn wir mal
vernünftig auf toilette wollten sie mit
zu mcdonald's an die conti gegangen und
jetzt wurden sie sogar auch die
schultoiletten scouts noch angesprochen
ich würde gerne wissen was das ist und
ob das ihr einziger beitrag dazu ist
dass die leute oder die schüler in
frankfurt endlich mal wieder vernünftig
auf toilette gehen können und jetzt der
herr links vor einem orangen pullover
glaube ich genau danach erstmal schnitt
aus danke hallo giuseppe giannini auf
frankfurter unternehmer eine ganz
einfache frage wir haben viel über geld
ausgeben gesprochen mich würde
interessieren und zwar an alle
kandidaten wie kriegen wir den geld
rein in die stadt die stelle der
wettbewerb mit internationalen
metropolen wollen alle das gleiche wie
wir finanz und digital und ich finde wir
lassen hier eine riesen chance ungenutzt
mit unserer knotenpunkt mit unserer
verkehrslage und lassen uns da abhängen
und das könnte in zukunft viel mehr
kosten als das was wir jetzt bereit sind
auszugeben um einen die zukunft zu bauen
die wir da nicht haben wir haben danke
entscheidung bleiben sie war gerade
mikrofon ich habe die frage ehrlich
gesagt nicht ganz verstanden also frage
ich wären früher wie kommen wir als
stadt frankfurt an geld im wettbewerb
mit anderen europäischen metropolen wenn
es darum geht zukunftstechnologien
nachhaltig hier in frankfurt zu binden
also geldeinnahmen um zu investieren in
zukunft nicht ausgehen
also jetzt sammeln mal gesammelt und
fangen glaube ich malerei nacharbeiten
das mal ab die erste frage ging an herrn
feldmann wie stehen sie zur gruppe hat
ist mit dem burschen sie haben das recht
auf eine antwort in vier wochen das
müssen wir hinkriegen und es ist einfach
mehr kultur mehr maxima culpa es ist
halt einfach nicht gut gelaufen das muss
man nachbauen und man büros tatsächlich
der hatte alexander anwesend die haben
einen roten kopf grad
meine damen und herren paulskirchen
sanierung ja wir haben augenblicklich
das geld dafür im budget aber es ist
tatsächlich ein nationales symbol groko
relativ einfach zu beantworten für mich
weil ich habe einen klaren
kriterienkatalog einem sehr langen
interview mit
tageszeitung aus berlin die taz heißt
raus gegeben wo ich gesagt habe es ist
so dass für mich das kriterium ist jetzt
nicht parteipolitisch sonst
oberbürgermeister kriegen wir mehr geld
für den wohnungsbau kriegen wir mit geld
für den öffentlichen nahverkehr kriegen
wir mit geld für die bildung das ist die
maßgabe wonach auch ich mich als
parteimitglied dann entscheiden werde
weil die stadt liegt mir erstmal im
herzen und das sind diese ganzen
taktischen geplänkel wieder im
augenblick laufen für mich im augenblick
relativ langweilig ich kann es kaum noch
hören dann gab es eine sehr konkrete
frage wie kriegt man geld in die stadt
dazu gibt es zwei dinge die fakten
basiert sind das erste ist wir haben
lange vernachlässigt unsere industrie
zehn prozent der beschäftigten arbeiten
dort wir haben dort aber über weitere 30
prozent der steuereinnahmen weil wir so
ein bisschen auf die banken gucken ich
bin immer sehr dafür dass wir unsere
banken schlägen aber faktisch ist es so
dass der gesamte sektor weniger
gewerbesteuer zahlt als eine große
industriefirmen im frankfurter westen
das heißt was wir im augenblick
diskutieren wohnungsbau ist auch immer
eine frage von gewerbeansiedlungen
interkommunalen projekten beispielsweise
mit maintal wasser josef mit dem herrn
frank der so viel gescholten wird nicht
von mir hin steht das finde ich sehr gut
und das zweite ist natürlich das thema
digitalisierung wir haben augenblick
400.000 quadratmeter die zusagen online
sind den größten internet knotenpunkt
nicht in hessen nicht in deutschland
nicht in europa sondern weltweit global
wir waren immer ein kommunikations
schnittpunkt für die menschen seit
hunderten von jahren sind sie jetzt
wieder und die industrie sagt selber
wenn ein bisschen gas gibt können wir
auch 600.000 quadratmetern und das sind
die beiden geld bringen
neben unserem klassischen sektoren wie
pharma life science biotechnologie ist
es diese neue sektor it bereich da kann
eine sehr interessante sehr spezielle
frage also ich
die fernsehserie das hat aber wir
sollten sie vielleicht nicht in extens
so heute abend hier diskutieren
das war die nach der paulskirche wenn
ich sie richtig verstanden habe leiden
sie unter dem zustand und zwar nicht nur
der zustand wie er jetzt ist sondern
vielleicht auch unter der etwas kargen
modernen gestaltung und ist ja der
paulskirche steht soweit ich weiss unter
denkmalschutz so einfach wird das nicht
aber ich muss ehrlich dazu stellung
nehmen sondern gibt es jemanden hier aus
der kandidatenrunde der jetzt sagt
jawohl wir stellen die paulskirche so
wieder her
diese 1848 49 aus oder gibt es da die
meinungen wir sollten sie vielleicht
mehr zu sanieren und sagen das ist ein
denkmal was für den wiederaufbau steht
das hatten wir so lassen gibt es in
ihren zeitarbeitern dazu sagen ja ich
glaube in der tat ist es so dass die
paulskirche die ja die bedeutung für uns
hier hat als erstes parlament auf
deutschem boden nicht richtig
wertgeschätzt wird
und es hat mir ein schneider ist gerade
daran festzustellen was an sanierungen
notwendig ist vom dach bis außenarbeiten
aber mal aus meiner sicht reicht das
überhaupt nicht aus es ist
denkmalgeschützt und ich hatte bereits
kontakt mit der bundesebene und habe
dort nachgefragt ob man nicht geld dafür
dieses denkmal generieren könnte das
wurde mir schriftlich bestätigt
abgelehnt und deshalb glaube ich letzten
endes müssen wir aus der frankfurter
bürgerschaft heraus etwas für unsere
paulskirche tun
wir haben gute stiftungen hier es wird
uns nichts anderes übrig bleiben aber
ich glaube wir müssen gemeinsam ran
gehen um auch nochmal darzustellen wer
hat teilgenommen in diesem parlament
das kann man ja gar nicht in dieser
kargen ausrüstung ersehen heinrich von
gagern zum beispiel gaga und gymnasium
das hat ja alles bedeutung in unserer
stadt das ist zu kurz gekommen und daran
müssen wir arbeiten
vielleicht das was vor bleiben wir
gleich bei ihnen diese frage war die
nach den schultoiletten ich bitte um
verzeihung wenn das etwas kurz von mir
abgehandelt wurde wir haben ja zeitlich
befristet nur rede möglichkeit und ich
hatte am haus am dom hat sich diesen
masterplan vorgestellt hatte war auch
der neue elternbeirats vertreter da es
gibt ja eine online umfrage zu dem thema
der ich mich angeschlossen habe weil es
natürlich nicht nur mit dem scout getan
ist sondern es muss eine sanierung der
toiletten stattfinden das ist auch in
diesen haushaltsplan den ich für den
masterplan entwickelt habe eingebucht
und natürlich wissen wir auch von den
schulen dass es nicht damit alleine
getan ist es muss eine beteiligung aus
der schule heraus kommen das war die
idee vom scout aber es muss auch
regelmäßig geputzt dort werden vor ort
und es war die ehemalige leiterin der
schillerschule zb anwesend frau thekla
sehr aktiv wer sie noch kennen
die hat gesagt bei uns damals hat es
funktioniert indem wir uns putzkräfte
dann mit dem gymnasium nebenan geteilt
haben also das ist alles in diesen plan
aufgeführt aber das wird jetzt zu lang
es ist für unsere schülerinnen und
schüler und ich muss sagen auch als
elternteil nicht vertretbar dass diese
rahmenbedingungen die
grundvoraussetzungen nicht gegeben sind
der herr hier der erste ist herzlich
geld wollen sie noch hier
dann wird es schön hier von mein name
ist hens ist
sachsenhausen wenn ich die amtszeit von
ihnen herr feldmann revue passieren
lassen das habe ich jetzt vor dem abend
getan fällt mir auf sie haben sich
während ihrer amtszeit beruflich
weitergebildet ist die windreich die
sportler straßenbahnfahrer stadtführer
und museumsführer und der neuen altstadt
und im historischen museum
meine frage ist an die drei damen und in
den stein wenn sie die wahl gewinnen
haben sie derartige pläne sich auch
während der amtszeit weiterzubilden und
fällt bald die frage sollten sie eine
zweite amtszeit bekommen haben sie schon
pläne wie sie wären die amtszeit war der
bild
dann hatte ich hier den herrn im
karierten hemd in der dritten reihe
dann kommen sie dran dankeschön
mein name ist hansen aus der
nordweststadt ich habe es natürlich eine
frage zu dem stadtteil und an sie alle
aber besonders an herrn feldmann und die
neben frage davon noch an die frau
leyland herr feldmann
sie wissen dass wir uns sehr viele
gedanken machen wir würden uns ja freuen
wir uns auch mal besuchen kommen in
unserem stadtteil das ist soweit ich
weiß zumindest in dem zusammenhang nicht
passiert aber sie haben in ihrer
broschüre
in dieser broschüre ihrer werbebroschüre
für ihre wahl haben sie einen satz aus
ihren leistungen der folgendermaßen
lautet lebenswerter stadtteil
beschlossen
ich möchte sie fragen wieso der stadt
lebenswert sein kann wenn die 3,5 fache
einwohnerdichte gegenüber nordweststadt
und niederursel hier geplant wird und
wenn die a5 ja unbestritten nicht nicht
wegdiskutiert werden kann also die
schlechte luft die weder weiterhin
drüber und ich möchte sie fragen wieso
sie beschlossen sagen denn sie dürften
genau wissen dass in dem beschluss steht
dass das ergebnis offen ist die
untersuchung die derzeit läuft und dass
das ob und das wie diskutiert wird im
parlament und das impliziert nach
deutschen sprachgebrauch das dann
entschieden wird erst ob wirklich gebaut
wird oder ob eine bauplanung gemacht
wird sie können doch den wählern nicht
sagen das sei beschlossen und das sei
ihre leistung dass das beschlossen ist
und ich finde das ist unaufrichtig das
ist unwahr und so kann man nicht umgehen
mit den bürgern kritisch da hatte ich
den herrn hinter ihm ja schon nah mein
name ist hans peter hoh mich wohnen in
der innenstadt im mehrgenerationenhaus
der caritas und ich wollte noch was zur
integration sagen
da gibt es wirklich noch luft nach oben
und für mich wäre seine idee als
frankfurt als vorschlag zu machen den
bahnhofsvorplatz der demnächst gestaltet
werden soll
als platz der weltkulturen
auszuschreiben und weil dann könnte
vielleicht auch das wäre ein wichtiges
zeichen um zu sagen
kommunikation ist nötig und mehr
kommunikation mit den mit den migranten
und dann könnten wir unsere
vorstellungen vom leben zum beispiel ich
bin schwul eben auch dort dokumentieren
und eben die migranten könnten eben auch
ihre vorstellungen dokumentieren
ja das wäre so sehen wir auch eine
vierte die dame hinter letzten reihe von
mir aus gesehen
dann brauchen wir doch mal ein schnitt
guten abend elke schröder ich komme aus
dem lärm geplagten frankfurter süden
und ich weiß dass der herr feldmann
gerne das nachtflugverbot ausweiten
möchte und mich würde interessieren die
haltung der anderen kandidaten dazu gut
der herr in der ersten reihe ist hier
mit mir vielleicht nicht ganz böse wenn
ich so eine frage mehr als polemik gegen
herrn feldmann gewertet habe uns jetzt
nicht frage welche
weiterbildungsprogramme die anderen vier
kandidaten machen wollen ich glaube der
punkt den sie machen wollten
ist auch so angekommen wir kommen zur
nordweststadt der herr zitierte wohl aus
ihrer wahlbroschüre dass sie etwas als
beschlossen dargestellt hätten herr
feldmann
ich habe auf wenn ich ihre antwort auf
meine frage eben noch richtig in
erinnerung habe haben sie etwas von
prüfen gesagt und habe eben nicht vom
beschlossen gesprochen
gibt es da ist tatsächlich ein
widerspruch den zwischen der aussage der
broschüre und dem was sie hier gesagt
haben nein die varianten werden geprüft
aber die koalition hat den neuen
stadtteil beschlossen auch öffentlich
verkündet die koalitionsspitzen von cdu
spd und
grün waren dann die entsprechend
sprecher der magistrats gruppen haben
das öffentlich verkündet und haben das
als gemeinsame verabredung und beschluss
verkündet dass nämlich ernsthaft das ist
etwas was ich als oberbürgermeister so
unterstützt habe dazu stehe ich aus aber
ich möchte soll halt was sagen ich bin
jemand der jede woche in der
nordweststadt ist der dort eine schule
hatte jetzt ein seniorenprojekt hat
eingeweiht und viele viele bezüge dahin
hat vom sport bis eben zum persönlichen
bereich ich glaube dass in der
nordweststadt mal gut beraten ist sehr
genau hinzuhören was einem vom wm
versprochen wird wenn man den zeitungen
liest zum beispiel die faz kann man dort
lesen dass eine kandidatin dem frau dr
bernadette weyland sagt wir brauchen das
gar nicht so die folgen bis sind diese
initiative heimatboden wir brauchen das
auch nicht bei steinbach weil das ist
irgendwie ganz fürchterlich sondern wir
verdichten nach und da sage ich ihnen
explizit ist genannt worden die
nordweststadt und wenn ich mir vorstelle
dass wir in dieser stadt in der
nordweststadt die sowieso schon recht
dichte bebauung hat und es gab noch den
vorschlag und der liederbach und
fechenheim und das gallus und den
dornbusch es gibt natürlich auch mal
kurz moment nachzudenken wie es aussieht
im nordend bornheim süden da entscheide
ich mich dafür dass ich ein teil der
agrarischen flächen im frankfurter
norden nutzen will wählt für bezahlbaren
wohnungen weil es für mich eine
faktische alternative ist gegen
expansiven verdichtung und ich bin
überzeugt dass auch die menschen dort
die ich dort bredehöft treffe ich gehe
dort ein kauf mit meiner familie
verstehen auch dass es wichtig ist wenn
man luft zum atmen dieser stadt haben
will dass man nicht sagen kann weiter
nördlich darf keiner keinen stadtteil
sein
aber uns die winter hinter höhe für die
wenn zugeknallt mit beton die letzten
quadratmeter grün das ist die
entscheidung verstehen dass entscheiden
sie auch mit bei der
oberbürgermeisterwahl
deshalb bitte ich in dieser frage für
unsere unterstützung für den neuen
stadtteil und gegen zubetonieren
wirklich von den kleinen flächen die wir
noch
diese stadt okay das hatten wir ja auch
in der wohnung style von schon mal
gehört ich wollte jetzt noch mal nach
sowohl als historische durch noch ganz
kurz würde ich jetzt gern noch wie
weiland die ganze zeit die gelegenheit
geben was ich habe nicht verstanden was
was herr feldmann gerade mit heimatboden
gemeinde können sie das nur kurz
erläutert diesen ausdruck möchte ich
wirklich einfach von mir weisen
es gibt eine initiative die historischen
zeitabschnitten unterwegs und diesen
ausdruck habe ich nie verwand und das
ist jetzt sehr merkwürdig was gerade
hier geschieht
ich weise das einfach von mir ich habe
auch nicht die absicht keine hat die
absicht so nach zu verdichten dass man
nicht mehr leben kann
das sind das sind einfach sprüche die er
jetzt hier rüber kommen
es gibt auch nicht dieses entweder oder
sondern jeder weiß in unserer stadt beim
der siedlung gibt wo ergänzend wohnraum
ok müssen die diskussionen noch mal
artikel und einfach die nächste frage
neben nicht weiterkommen bei ihnen war
schade da hast vielleicht waren
bahnhofsvorplatz als platz der
weltkulturen ausbauen hatten sie gesagt
das habe ich auch eher als eine
interessante anregung verstanden und das
nächste was wir konkret fragen können
und da würde ich vielleicht dann den
eine gelegenheit geben die in der
fragerunde bis jetzt noch nicht dran
waren
wollen sie das nachtflugverbot ausweiten
professor wenn sie anfangen mögen gerne
sonst machen wir die einfache reinach
jahr wollen wir also weil das wir
brauchen ein achtstündiges
nachflugverbot auf jeden fall und vor
allem das ist auch wichtig auf die
einhaltung also für die einheit und zu
sagen da wir haben jetzt die situation
dass unter anderem
unternehmen wie ryanair das flugverbot
auswärts haben von 23 bis 5 uhr
systematisch unterläuft und deswegen ja
ausweitung des nachtflugverbots und ich
will auch sagen dass ich es wichtig
finde dass der bauantrag der jetzt
vorliegt für dieses neue billigflieger
dieser billigflug steigt der jetzt am
frankfurter flughafen entstehen soll da
liegt die baugenehmigung jetzt bei der
stadt frankfurt
und ich finde es wichtig den nicht zu
genehmigen weil es einfach schlechte
arbeitsbedingungen schlechte
arbeitsplätze sind und das
nachtflugverbot systematischen lauf wird
und dass noch mehr fluglärm bedeutet für
die menschen den betroffenen stadtteil
ok herrscht ein
nach dem verbot ausweiten ja oder nein
ich bin ein freund des flughafens weil
jeder der den flughafen mal genießen
konnte egal wohin gereist ist weiß
welches asset wir im rhein main gebiet
haben nur was ich überhaupt nicht
verstehe ist dass die landesregierung
und fraport nicht hinbekommen den
frieden mit den menschen von oberrad
oder sachsenhausen niederrad bis nach
goldstein hinzubekommen
ich habe nachgewiesen dass in den
randstunden von 22 bis 23 uhr und von 5
uhr bis 6 uhr im grunde die
nordwestlandebahn überhaupt nicht
gebraucht wird sondern dieser verkehrt
in dieser zeit stattfindet auf dem
parallel bahn system dargestellt werden
kann
deshalb verstehe ich nicht dr schuld
dass er nicht sagt okay dort hat der
flug vergehen der vergangenheit immer
stattgefunden weshalb muss sich die
menschen von oberrad bis goldstein mit
diesem zusätzlichen lärm belasten
deshalb werde ich so ich gewählt werde
im aufsichtsrat von fraport dafür sorgen
dass in diesen zwei stunden die lande
tätigkeit für den nord west bahn nicht
stattfindet weil sie auf anderen bahnen
darstellbar ist okay preusker war es
genau gemerkt
auch die frage an sie nachflugverbot
ausweiten ja oder nein
jeder mensch hat recht sieben stunden
nach zu schlafen kinder haben recht nach
staffel und ich glaube sieben bis acht
stunden sondern ich weiß ich dass er
sieben stunde wäre und wenn es acht
stunde wäre auf jeden fall nur wichtig
ist dass man wirklich auch so dran hält
jetzt gerade habe ich heute gelesen von
ministerium dass man druck auf ein jahr
und anderen wirklich aus dass sie sich
daran halten und das geht doch überhaupt
das ist heute haben mir ihr ministerium
gesehen auch berichte und statistiken
ich bin auf jeden fall dafür dass wir
wirklich sorge tragen
aber im moment ist ja auch coco wieder
dran die sparer sowie nachtflugverbot
wieder aus da wird überhaupt nicht
darüber diskutiert daher wird das wird
aber jetzt ein nein das wird auch auf
der bundesebene eine regelung geben kann
dass es uns auch vorschreibt und ich bin
auf jeden fall da führt dass wir
nachtflugverbot wirklich uns daran ein
hat dann haben wir vielleicht warte
jetzt nicht wir machen jetzt noch heute
gerne wegen ein paar gesagt sein
entschuldigung das habe jetzt für heute
sozusagen nicht mehr verweigern sie noch
zum schluss nachflugverbot ausweiten ja
oder nein tut mir leid also herr
feldmann hat das in seinem wahlprogramm
2012 schon verbraucht versprochen dass
er das nachtflugverbot ausdehnen wird
bisher ist nichts getan wenn er dann die
aufsichtsratssitzung wahrnehmen wird
denn ein drittel gehört der stadt
frankfurt
dann kann er sich dafür stark machen
darauf können wir warten und sie selber
ausweiten ja oder nein also außerdem
muss man muss einen masterplan man muss
einen masterplan für die stadt frankfurt
machen das kann die stadt frankfurt
umsetzen und da gehören solche dinge wie
lärmschutzmaßnahmen die landesregierung
eingefordert hat und nacht flug der plan
dazu ich finde das ist nicht gut dass
man sich nicht gegenseitig ausreden ist
ich habe auch keine lust gegen jemanden
an zu reden
also okay damit ist meine frage beim ok
ich glaube dann machen wir hier nochmal
stetig mehr eröffnet die letzte frage
runde die erste meldung dort vorne und
dann wechseln wir hier auf die seite
britische wird jetzt konzentration auf
die fragen musste weil hardy
politikwissenschaftler
vielen dank herr steinbach vor ihrer
statistik und vor er kritik was sie
geübt haben
ich betone das ist ihrer vorlassen
voller feste zahl von kriminalität der
araber oder nordafrikaner zu betonen ich
glaube wir aber ohne selbst man kann
keine kritik üben ohne selbstkritik zu
üben und hier erlaube ich mir als bürger
dieser stadt kritik an die mehrheit an
die mehrheit der bevölkerung hier zu
üben in beamter zeit von von unserer
oberbürgermeister sind zahlreichen davon
von moschee in frankfurt wurden von der
deutschen polizei gestürmt
die liberaler die sehr guter zeitung
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung hat das
betitelt hat gesagt in zehn bundesländer
sind erfolgreiche aktionen auch moscheen
sie hat das gelobt ich frage mich in der
stadt wo jede wo jedes kindergarten
jüdischer kindergarten jüdischer
einrichtungen wörter von wohl sei
bewacht und die die die islamische
moscheen und gebetsräume werden von der
polizei gestoppt ist das kein problem
moral dass die erste frage an die wiener
sogar meist gelassen sie ja bei der
ersten frage weil wir ja noch sehr sehr
viele andere fragen wenn ich länger
geredet als die anderer redner die
geräte haben
aber ich versuche mal die 20 prozent der
muslime in dieser stadt die stimme von
den zur lautern und meine frage gibt an
janine an verweisen
herr oberbürgermeister hat jährlich der
jahrestag
geburtstag von den staat israel betreut
und da war und da hat immer unter seine
betreuen die stadt israel israel betreut
und gelobt und die partnerschaft auch
mit talla einfach gefordert auf der
anderen seite her fällt man hat immer
erzeugung in absehbarer zeit mit einer
frage die man
gelehnt unserer einladung von arabisch
organisation abgelehnt das erste sind
sich teilnehmen und das finde ich führte
frage einfach weiß man wenn die
oberbürgermeistern sein werden werden
sie auch die selber tatsachen was hört
wenn man gesagt haben dieser doppelmoral
mit dem umgang mit muslimen juden tun
oder werden sie fiel auch die
partnerschaft mit der stadt gaza in
palästina auch annehmen dass als
partnerstadt von frankfurt sein wird ich
frage sie einfach ob das okay danke
schön federn jetzt hatten wir hätte ich
hier die termine erste reihe eine seite
bitteschön
mein name ist marita kneisel ich komme
aus schwanheim und bin für den stadtteil
auch kinderbeauftragte meine frage geht
an den hand feldmann
herr feldmann ich habe in der faz vom
fünften februar im interview auf die
frage sind sie jetzt sie sind jetzt
sechs jahre bürgermeister hat sie das
amt verändert sie legen hier dass sie
früher auch mal kinder und jugend aber
in der kinder und jugendarbeit
gearbeitet haben
sie haben gesagt dass sie in ihrer
amtszeit jeden monat eine schule besucht
haben
meines erachtens bei fünfeinhalb jahren
gibt es 66 schulen hier in frankfurt ist
ihnen da auch bewusst geworden in
welchem maroden zustand die schulen sind
das die eine frage die andere frage in
schwanheim gibt es zwei grundschulen
eine schule davon ist inklusions schule
die seit 2014 eigentlich schon
barrierefrei sein sollte und
entsprechend umgebaut sein sollte bis
heute ist hier kein aufzug so dass die
kinder in diesem schulgebäude immer mit
einer ja die kinder eine sackkarre mit
einem assistenten
die treppe hoch gezogen werden das
zweite ist in der mine specht schule ist
seit 20 jahren ein antrag bei der stadt
für den austausch eine glasfront des
musik saales da frage ich mich wie kann
so war sein 20 jahre liegt dieser antrag
immer noch irgendwo unten im
dornröschenschlaf
dann hätten wir vielleicht noch 80 jahre
zeigt ok danke schön
die beiden in der mitte entschuldigung
sei gerade da ich glaube der herr hatte
sich hinter ihn noch schick mir den
roten pullover da machen was
pragmatische weise gleich mit guten
abend mein name ist hier kostet man sich
wohl in frankfurt eschersheim eben
zweiten deutschen fernsehen gab es eine
reportage den hatte sich bahn ohne plan
da war die rede davon dass der s bahn
ausbau wohl gleis kapazitäten frei
schaufeln so dass die deutsche
bundesbahn dann auf den vier statt zwei
gleisen auch güterzüge fahren lassen
kann
es war die rede von 100 stück die so
quer durch die innenstadt fahren das
klang so ein bisschen nach
schildbürgerstreich und ich wüsste gerne
von ihnen insbesondere von herrn
feldmann was sie davon halten also noch
mal kurz zu verständnis sie machen ja
sich den vierspurigen ausbau richtung
friedberg doch den mainzer okay da wird
sie von innen stadt sprachen ich dachte
mal sie s bahn tunnel oder so okay jetzt
bitteschön die dame in der fünften reihe
und der herr daneben dann und dann
machen wir schluss denn wir nähern uns
jetzt doch längst haben die zweieinhalb
stunden die beide noch bitte so mein
name ist helga malewski
ich bin hier lehrerin an einer
frankfurter schule und ganz speziell
jetzt an frau grünberg sie haben vorhin
ja bildung und sie wollen das ja auch
irgendwo im mittelpunkt stellen
ich habe selbst mit der versorger im
schulentwicklungsplan mitgearbeitet und
das war ja eine ihrer aus ihrer partei
damals eine abgeordnete und jetzt mir
geht es darum dass die bildung
eigentlich anders aussieht für mich sind
sie da ein bisschen weltfremd
ich lade sie gerne auch ein dass ich
meine schule anzuschauen
ich bin an einer realschule habe dort
mindestens zwei drittel hauptschüler
sitzen weil man die hauptschulen ja hier
in frankfurt leider geschlossen hat und
an den gymnasien bei uns um die ecke ist
die villa schule dort sitzen vielleicht
ein drittel vielleicht auch mehr
realschüler die 1 stand unserer schule
sein müssten und dass der bildung dass
die bildung damit immer weiter nach
unten sinkt das haben sie alle denke ich
noch nicht begriffen dass man her geht
und das war das letzte mal beim
bürgergespräch als hier der
kultusminister war der selbst gesagt hat
es wird runtergesetzt beim abitur ich
glaub frau weiland sie waren auch da
das deutsch wird noch mal runter gesetzt
dass wir uns so keine bildungseliten
schaffen und dann würde ich gerne von
ihnen persönlich wissen wie ich nicht
integrative eltern dazu bewege
integrativ zu werden
mein name ist helmut malewski bin
gebürtiger frankfurter wurde in
eckenheim
wir haben hier gehört dass der haushalt
der stadt frankfurt defizitär ist
wir haben auch gehört dass hier
günstiger wohnraum gebaut werden soll
ich weiß zwar nicht wie das bei den
baupreisen funktionieren soll
wir haben gehört dass kita-plätze
umsonst sein
das haus hier soll umgebaut werden mit
einem dreistelligen millionenbetrag und
so weiter und so fort
bevor wir uns weiter irgendwelchen
träumereien widmen wäre es nicht
sinnvoll mal den haushalt der stadt
frankfurt zu konsolidieren gut wunderbar
dann arbeiten wir die fragen gerade noch
ab die erste frage ging an herrn
feldmann herr feldmann der vorwurf war
an sie
es war ein doppelter der erste war dass
moscheen von der polizei quasi überfall
gestürmt wird war glaube ich der begriff
und muss und synagogen und andere
jüdische einrichtungen geschützt ich
kann mir jetzt persönlich an keine
störung erinnern aber weiß nicht ich
auch nicht vertiefen aber die zweite
frage war und die können vielleicht
konkrete hierauf frankfurter ebene
diskutieren
der herr sagte es gebe eine
städtepartnerschaft mit tel aviv wo
bleibt die städtepartnerschaft mit
gaza-stadt wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe
wie stehen sie dazu den moschee
stimmungen muss ehrlich sagen ich denke
da wo fundamentalistische verdacht es
wird wahrscheinlich auch eine moschee
durchsucht das kann sein
die stadt hat nicht die möglichkeiten
auch ich als oberbürgermeister wir alle
hier haben nicht die möglichkeit
irgendwelche stimmungen zu fahren lassen
die entscheidung der landespolizei und
des bundeskriminalamtes bzw
verfassungsschutz ob das gemacht wird so
einfach und so schwierig ist das
manchmal
die frage bei den städtepartnerschaften
die halterung für sehr wichtig wir haben
eine sehr gut funktionierende
städtepartnerschaft mit tel aviv wir
haben eine sehr gut funktionierende
städtepartnerschaft mit unsere
muslimischen partner stadt eskisehir und
wir haben ein jugendaustausch wo
jugendliche aus tel aviv aus es geschehe
und aus frankfurt regelmäßig
zusammenkommen zwar fußball austauschen
ersten runde
jetzt haben wir studentenaustausch die
stellen fest dass die probleme der
jugendlichen fragen von wohnungsnot
bildungssituation studiensituation
arbeitslosigkeit anscheinend global die
mir die gleichen sind
ich bin sehr entschlossen dem im zweiten
quartal nach kairo unsere weiteren
partnerstadt zu machen der läuft mir aus
meiner sicht zu wenig stadtparlament
kann beschließen ob es noch gaza-stadt
dazu nehmen will ich weiß das nicht es
ist nicht meine entscheidung des
entscheidens stadtparlament
nichtsdestotrotz finde ich gerade das
was mit eskisehir und tel aviv läuft
sehr gut und ich vertrete das auch
weiterhin weil ich glaube dass es gut
ist dass jüdische christliche und
muslimische menschen zusammenkommen
der zweite
das zweite ist die frage die ich nicht
beantworten durfte aber trotzdem
beantworten will die frage wie es mit
acht stunden schlafen ja kinder schlafen
neun bis zehn stunden op kandidaten
schlafen vielleicht sechs oder sieben
stunden und die durchschnittlichen
menschen schlafen acht stunden und jetzt
zu sagen die werden wir ein er das ganze
den flughafen retten indem wir die
situation der arbeitsplätze
verschlechtern indem wir mehr
billiglöhner dort reinholen halte ich
für den falschen weg wir sind ein
qualitäts flughafen mit hohen ansprüchen
und deshalb sage ich auch in dieser
frage der flughafen braucht den frieden
in der region brauche mit seinen
nachbarn auch in oberrad auch in die der
rat auch in sachsenhausen und nicht die
lärmpausen der landesregierung die die
menschen in den frankfurter süden
einfach nicht spüren
sie sehen keine pause deshalb platzt mir
der forderung nach nachtflugverbot für
acht stunden
er stach das letzte war die frage wie
ist das eher feldmann sie waren doch sie
ist jetzt nicht es hat nicht gerade ihre
radiomoderator bin würde ich gerne die
reihenfolge der fragen bestimmen jetzt
wollte erst einmal gehört hat mir den
ersten frage beruflichen wir hatten uns
dass wir die leute bleiben ich wollte
jetzt steigen ist doch mal fragen nach
der oder er wollte was sagen zu der
frage gaza-stadt und tel aviv weitere
städtepartnerschaft also so weichgespült
wie wahrscheinlich jeder andere
diskussionsteilnehmer an dem podium in
einer auskunft zu geben gedenkt bin ich
nicht ich sage ein klares nein solange
katjuscha raketen vom gazastreifen auf
israel abgeschossen werden gibt es keine
städtepartnerschaft mit gaza solange
hisbollah das sagen hat in gaza gibt es
keine städtepartnerschaft mit frankfurt
am main
was zu dieser frage dann war eine nette
geschichte mit dem haushalt ja der
einzige der augen auch bei in bild ich
stelle immer auch die frage als ich gebe
dir ja ja schön dass ihr alle so viel
sagen wollen aber es ist vielen dank für
das reißt ihnen jetzt also ja dankbar
war sehr interessant ich vielleicht darf
ich der dame aus schwaan haben ich bin
auch schwanheimer ich die erste schule
seemann ist der augustinerschule die
meine tochter besucht hat ich weiß genau
wovon sie reden ich gehörte auch ein
beirat an der sich um diese fragen
gekümmert hat und kann ihren frust
detail verstehen dass da immer noch
nichts passiert ist
mit dem umbau für die behinderten also
behindertengerechten umbau aber ich
würde sagen das ist jetzt ein bisschen
spezielle frage für dieses podium wenn
es recht ist wenn herr feldmann schon
sagte das dass sein mitarbeiter rote
köpfe haben dann haben sie jetzt erst
recht vielleicht rote köpfe oder
einander dezernaten ich lass das jetzt
mal so stehen und vielleicht kann er
fährt man nur ganz kurz durch ein nicken
zu verstehen geben dass er diese frage
demnächst irgendwie beantworten wird
oder dafür sorgt dass der magistrat sich
dazu verhält können wir uns so einigen
bevor wir jetzt über schwanheimer
schulprobleme hier sprechen
gut dann haben wir die frage mit den 100
güterzügen die auch künftig durch die
innenstadt was vielleicht nicht ganz
treffend ist aber sagen wir mal die
ebenfalls im westlichen teil frankfurts
durchrauschen würden wenn der
viergleisige ausbau der nach nach
friedberg kommt jetzt weiß ich nicht wer
möchte sich hier auf dem podium dazu
verhalten erstaunlich waren unterbrochen
worden dann können sie ja zu der frage
was ich sage deswegen gerne was dazu
weil ich mich früh positioniert hat mit
der damaligen stadtverordneten hannelore
otto die auch mit anwältin war zwei
statt vier
ich glaube dass sie recht haben die bahn
baut nicht im sinne von schnellerer
s-bahn diese strecke von bad vilbel nach
frankfurt west über berkersheim ginnheim
aus und er die bahn hat ein großes
interesse
ihre großen güterzüge möglichst schnell
auch durch frankfurt zu bekommen und
deshalb werden die zwei zusätzlichen
gleisen
gebaut ich halte es nicht für sinnvoll
weil ich glaube eine zukunftsträchtige
bahnpolitik kann doch nur sein wie wir
sie zum beispiel im rheintaler erleben
da werden die züge leiser gemacht und da
wird auch nachgedacht über alternative
führung strecken ich muss kein guter zug
durch frankfurt durchziehen weil
frankfurt ist nicht der nabel der welt
in der sache von umschlagsplatz für
güter die auf der auf dem bühl dazu
transportiert werden deshalb haben sie
mich auf ihrer seite
ich bin dezidiert gegen einen ausbau
dieser strecke
okay die zweitletzte frage kam von der
dame die gingen direkt an frau eskandari
grünberg da ging es um das thema oder um
die frage weil wenn ich es richtig in
erinnerung habe
wie bringt man nicht integrative eltern
dazu sich zu integrieren
an schulen vielleicht antworten sie
darauf ich glaube einen fragen wollen
noch davor ich glaube ich bin nicht
bildungs fremd wir haben
unterschiedliche vorstellungen von
bildung
ich fand die hauptschule nicht in
ordnung ich habe vorhin gesagt dass das
nicht die form ist dass wir die kinder
fordern können das ist eine form dass
wir ab vierter klasse entscheiden dass
die kinder in der hauptschule realschule
gehen diesen weg verhalte sich absolut
falsch und ich bin froh dass sie auch
dank wohnen eg es gibt intern hat
wirklich integrierte gesamtschulen dass
die kinder im laufe des wirklich ihren
schulweg bildungsweg entscheiden kann
wurde steht da dass es meine bildungs
vorstellen dass andere ist nicht eben
das zweite ist dass es die eltern
gewinnen können das verbleibt immer
natürlich ein thema die ich auch vorhin
gesagt haben wir haben eine reihe von
projekten gemacht dass wir die eltern
die mutter mutter gewinnen kann wer
mutter café in einigen schulen gemacht
in meinem amt in hand fünftürer
angelegenheit immer viele viele eltern
im rahmen mama lernt deutsch papa auch
erziehung von den eltern wie konnten die
eltern erreichen weil wir die sprache
von eltern der kulturelle hintergründe
von eltern verstanden haben und dann
kann ich ihnen sagen wenn wir den
richtigen weg gehen dann können wir die
eltern
daher kann ich sagen es gibt keinen
eltern dass das beste für ihre kinder
nicht wollen sondern wir müssen auch
wirklich die eltern unterstützen meine
erfahrung mit viele viele eltern gezeigt
wenn wir richtigen weg gefunden haben
und auch gegangen sind haben wir auch
die eltern erreicht okay vielleicht
können sie tatsächlich das thema auch
nachher nochmal weiter diskutieren ich
glaube da gibt es einfach sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen zu diesen
freude dass die letzte frage zum
frankfurter haushalt jetzt hier
behandelt wird da würde ich zunächst
gerne frau weiland zu fragen
die frage war ja oder weitergeben dass
die frage war ja wäre es nicht sinnvoll
den haushalt zu konsolidieren
da wird jetzt wahrscheinlich niemand
nein sagen deswegen erlaube ich mir die
frage insofern etwas anders zu stellen
dass ich frau weiland frage wie würden
sie denn als oberbürgermeisterin den
haushalt sanieren der derzeit
strukturell 300 millionen macht also die
stadt frankfurt hat ein kein
einnahmeproblem sondern ein
ausgabeproblem das ist offensichtlich
und da muss man einfach darf ich
ausreden oder wollen wir weiter so
verfahren vielleicht sind sie noch
lernfähig erstand ich glaube auch nicht
also da muss man von vorne anfangen
ich bin vieles von ihnen gewöhnt aber
reißen sich ein bisschen zusammen
also ich glaube wir müssen bei der beim
haushalt durchforsten wo können wir bei
den ausgaben kürzen wo müssen wir
priorisieren
deshalb hatte ich eingangs gesagt ist
das thema bildung ganz wichtig da müssen
wir in den nächsten fünf jahren eine
milliarde ausgegeben da wird uns nichts
anderes übrig bleibe ich bin eben ganz
glücklich dass die groko beschlossen hat
dass auf der bundesebene eben auch jetzt
das geld eingestellt wird was wir
abrufen können dass es unsere aufgabe
die wir in den nächsten jahren machen
müssen und es gibt natürlich noch
einnahmen die wir generieren können wenn
wir mit der digitalisierung in dieser
stadt anders umgehen stieg von einnahmen
ist mutig und ich weiß nicht ob ich froh
bist ja jetzt schon vorweg nehme ich
würde sie trotzdem kurze fragen wollen
noch sind sie denn dafür dass um
defizit zu sozusagen zu beheben der
gewerbesteuerhebesatz angehoben wird
ich bin nicht da absolut dagegen denn
wenn wir das tun würden dann wandern die
firmen ab es ist jetzt schon so dass
eschborn bad vilbel dort firmen hingehen
weil die hebesätze niedriger sind und
dass da würden dass das wäre ein unsinn
was wir machen wir sind ok frau wissler
welchem planeten sie den haushalt ins
lot zu bringen erzählt möchte erstmal
der aussage von frau weiland
widersprechen die sagt wir haben kein
einnahme sondern ein ausgabeproblem und
ich finde es auch ein bisschen als ich
mal davon abgesehen dass die
landesregierung der sie ja bis vor
kurzem angehört haben dieser stadt
frankfurt ziemlich teuer zu stehen kam
also wenn ich an den kommunalen
finanzausgleich die fehlbelegungsabgabe
und ein paar andere dinge denke also
dass war
wir haben ja auch mit dazu beigetragen
aber zum anderen finde ich schon
bemerkenswert dass die kandidatin der
cdu die seit so vielen jahren regiert er
sagt wir haben ein ausgabeproblem dass
dir das geld quasi mit vollen händen
raus geworfen aus dem fenster geworfen
würde finde ich zumindest eine
interessante aussage also ich gesagt
jetzt auch mal ich finde die die 250.000
euro pro kronleuchter im palmengarten
gesellschaftshaus hätte aber gegen die
sein müssen ja also es wird sich ja auch
viel geld zum fenster rausgeworfen aber
ich finde dass der problem ist doch dass
wir mehr geld brauchen insbesondere für
die investitionen und deswegen finde ich
gerade dass wir was wir vorhin
diskutiert haben bei den
sanierungsbedürftigen schulen
das zeigt doch gerade wenn man über
viele jahre hinweg sanierungen
verschleppt weil man das geld nicht
ausgeben will
dann hat man irgendwann die situation
dass ja die schulen einfach so
sanierungsbedürftig sind dass es gar
nicht mehr anders geht und dass viele
gleichzeitig saniert werden müssen und
wenn dann geld gespart wird weil
sanierungen dringend notwendige
sanierung instandhaltungen aber nicht
nicht gemacht werden immer noch mit dem
argument der generationengerechtigkeit
besonders absurd im falle der schule
schulen dann hat man irgendwann einen
riesigen sanierungsstau und den haben
wir den haben wir
im bereich der brücken den haben wir im
bereich der schulen den haben wir im
bereich der straßen im bereich des rpnv
wir reden jetzt über verkehrsprojekte
die jedoch faktisch selbst 80er jahren
geplant werden also wir haben ein ganz
gigantischen sanierungsstau und deswegen
finde ich hier muss natürlich der
investitionstätigkeit erfolgen weil das
ist einfach so dass die infrastruktur
auf verschleiß wert und da muss
unbedingt mehr passieren und dafür muss
man auch mehr geld in die hand nehmen so
jetzt haben wir gut zwei stunden
diskutiert ich glaube wir sind alle
ermattet vom diskutieren vom zuhören ich
fand es persönlich sehr spannend nein
jetzt machen wir ja mal schluss
entschuldigung wenn ich da jetzt so hart
bin aber ich denke wir haben es lange
diskutiert jeder ich glaube die redezeit
war auch einigermaßen fair verteilt
verteilt war mein eindruck ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und für ihre fragen
ich danke dem podium ganz herzlich
drei damen und zwei herren das hat man
auch nicht so oft ich gehen sie zur wahl
das schöne an einer also erhöhen sie die
idee die wahlbeteiligung gleichzeitig
können sie sicher sein dass ihre stimme
hier mehr zählt als bei anderen wahlen
treffen sie die richtige entscheidung
ich hoffe ihr dabei geholfen habe ich
noch ein satz sagen darf es gibt nach
der wahl wenn wir wissen wer der nächste
oder der gleiche oberbürgermeister sein
wird ein bürgergespräch dann im
historischen museum über die frage fast
das ausstellungskonzept taugt es gibt
viele befürworter es gibt auch kritiker
wir würden uns sehr freuen sie wieder
begrüßen zu können
sie werden davon rechtzeitig in der
zeitung gelesen und jetzt wünsche ich
ihnen einen guten heimweg 40 uhr nach
hause
vielen dank
[Applaus]